[Laughter]
[Music]
take me to the river
i wanna go i'll go
take me to your river i wanna go
i don't even know who sings that you
don't know who sees that song
leon bridges leon bridges yeah he's like
a folk
country sega black dude i think he's uh
louisiana's where he's from but about
five years ago he had a very popular
song that was like
a song that really charted well it was
called the river
that was that that was that song and
dinner it is and then what he does is
you wear jamie you know that dude i've
seen him before i don't know
but this song is like he's had other
songs
but for some reason this song resonated
with a lot of people
um in the country man it was like him
reminiscing what
um going to place what made him feel
good in the river i hope when we go over
to spotify we can play it
i don't think oh i could take me to your
river
i want to go
i'll go that's pretty much
it that's the one part everybody knows
it's acceptable now for people to wear
like neck
cart scarfs are you being insulted chips
no not at all it's what are you saying
no
if you had wore that at any other time
i'd be like what is on your neck and i
would explain it to be a gator
right a caterer i know what it is i know
the gator is on this this is what it is
you're wearing when you're sneaking up
on animals oh they don't wear
people well that color is not you can't
sneak up on anybody
okay pride well it's just gonna go isn't
that yeah i guess that's a rainbow yeah
it's not as traditional this is a
liberal
liberal game liberal gator yep it's
accepted by anything gay people
black people hispanic people i'm sorry
no worries my baby mother asked me about
weed jesus
don't you don't like me because you'll
like me why you keep blowing me up about
weed you said you don't like she likes
your weed i mean they like something man
what happened to your thumb i got shot
who shot you
that's a question i haven't found the
answer to really
it was this [ __ ] happened so quick joe i
didn't really go to get a good look at
the person the person that shot me
um not too many people around and
witness it
but i have the wound to show that i got
shot
what was the situation i was my dog you
know i got a little i got a new zone
he's adorable
listen that's as adorable as a dog gets
ladies and gentlemen look at that
little cutie yo can you see her on on
camera
yo this is my emotional support that's
maggie yeah that's maggie maggie come
here sweetie
come here maggie give me honey she's a
dork she doesn't know what coffee is she
like
she don't know she know what weed is but
she don't know what coffee is but i was
protecting her
some people were tr joe you want to hear
the story about how i got shot or what
yeah i was protecting her honor right i
was protecting her
from a hell of bullets it was a gang it
was a lot of people
i don't remember all of that but i got
shot at my [ __ ] thumb
where were you in the streets oh just
regular
yeah i was i was
and that happens sometimes joe you put
yourself hanging in the streets
you put yourself in some unforgiving
situations and that's what happened to
me and that's how i got my
[ __ ] thumb shot to [ __ ] off and
that's the story i'm talking
that's the story that i'm sticking to so
you got caught in the crossfire
a hell of bullets jesus christ 45 shots
rang out
really legitimately
wow and this is the only injury i
sustained
i'm very very happy that that's the only
injury you sustained you're not happy
about it joe because when i love you
come on i know you love me but when i
told you i got shot
you continued to question me about well
danielle that's because you're donnell
right but you continue to i didn't
question you like i didn't believe you
you did 100 percent you said it so
casually that's what
i said do you want to drink he said i
can't i'm on antibiotics
i said what happened i got shot that's
it
usually any of any of my other friends
who've been shot if i said hey man
what happened and they said i got shot
it didn't just end right there
they would say it's the craziest story
ever man yeah but you know
i'm away to the car and i had my little
dog right i was protecting her
and that's the story that i told but the
thing that you didn't believe me
if someone said he got shot you can't
say i didn't believe you that's not true
it didn't look
the look of your face is like it's
unusual the way you were describing it
i got shot and then you wouldn't say
anything more just like what's yours
black people don't
no what happened how'd you get shot well
you remember i had a disagreement with
so-and-so well we finally had an
opportunity our paths crossed
we found a situation where those
energies came together we was like
how are we going to settle this right it
wasn't like that
i understood it wasn't like that it was
a okay and you don't want to
get specific about details no i don't
want to get specific i just want you to
respect the fact that i got shot
i believe that you got shot i do respect
it i'm sad that you got shot but i'm
glad you're okay
i'm better i'm good so how is your thumb
doing is it going to be all right
yep it's gonna be good you know we got
all the bullet fragments out of it
you know we avoided the surgery so i'm
gonna be good just gotta get the range
of motion back
oh that's real good they didn't have to
do any surgery and tendons or anything
like that
nope i got lucky i have a friend who cut
his finger on a window man and he never
got his fingers back again his fingers
are like this
curled i know everybody knows a
[ __ ] like that and we've all
made fun of that [ __ ]
we've made fun of the person that you
know that don't have a thumb
but i'm telling you doing this after me
surviving this gunshot [ __ ]
just butting in my pants become a task
that i took advantage i took took for
granted right
the point i'm making is that you're
lucky to have
all of your limbs all of your [ __ ] on
your body yep
if you don't appreciate it until one
[ __ ] gone well i think that's
the case with everything right like we
didn't appreciate how good we had it
before the lockdown
before kova came around nobody
appreciated how good we really had it we
was living in a moment
we were all so spoiled we were spoiled
by how good everything was
but we didn't think it was spoiled
because that was what was going on
right until [ __ ] shifted and then same
thing like you lose your thumb
you're like oh [ __ ] you know i really do
appreciate
uh doing those three spots that night
you know what i mean
i appreciate the fact that i could just
walk with my family
anywhere and i wouldn't be judged i
wouldn't be discriminated against
whatever
it'd just be like there goes joe and his
family not just like do you have a mask
or not
right you know but i do believe that
it took a pandemic for people to really
realize
what the most important things in life
are i think so for sure i think at the
beginning people were nicer
because they were scared and they were
like it was almost like post 9 11
feeling right like we're all in this
together
right that didn't last very long it was
unrealistic to think that everybody's
gonna be that way people don't get
frustrated
once also resources started getting low
and people started realizing they're not
gonna be able to work for a long [ __ ]
time
did you see the the governor got busted
did you see the photos which governor
governor california he got busted for
what got busted going to a restaurant
with 12 people no social distancing no
masks
all the [ __ ] that he's been preaching
for he didn't do they were saying that
he was in
outdoors like his people said it was
outdoors but now they have photos of it
100 percent indoors right they're all
endorsed but the thing is
the unrealistic part about that you know
people got to
push their platform this match has has
been crazy
but me i know it shouldn't be like this
and i know it's like but what does that
[ __ ] girls helping you
but what does it represent when i see
[ __ ]
like that in a situation that no mass
not socially distant
i just assumed that they all been tested
and they all have been in a bubble
situation well that's
because you've been in a bunch of bubble
situations like right wait
dave did the shows down in yellow
springs you bubbled me first i bubble
you here you're the first person you're
the first person you didn't rape my nose
you ra raped my finger
i didn't do it yes you did you hired a
nurse you made somebody do it
you could call it whatever the [ __ ] you
want to do but she worked for you that's
true
and you forced that that she had to do
it well i just suggested it probably a
good idea for everybody yeah but
they but it was good for everybody and
you knew that so we know like that's a
bubble world
yeah but it's not surprising that you
see the governor in a situation like
that because i'm pretty sure
it doesn't send out the right message
but i'm pretty sure
that the [ __ ] was tested well
that's what he should have said
they can't say that because they're a
politician and everybody go wait a
minute if i just test people can i go to
work
like what dave's doing with all his
shows yeah test people in the audience
and you can have a full audience you can
you know you have a bunch of people that
are healthy
you know you you you're taking the
measures
to create that safety yes it's a bubble
here's the thing that
a lot of people understand is that like
you could literally
create your own bubble yes like i know
people
in certain states you have to meet a
certain requirement to be tested
you can't be attested unless you have
she starts showing symptoms
but you can create your bubble there's
testing almost everywhere
there's an opportunity for people to get
tested it's a little harder than that
for most people because
but most people have been stupid most
people in terms of like just peoples of
just your access to it it's not that
common where you can go to a place and
get a quick test yet
okay so then what's the difference and i
may be wrong that this may be my
ignorance like california like
i know the situation like at dodger
stadium
you know i'm saying like for the most
part anybody with i guess a
california idea whatever they can get
tested no but hold on you know that
takes
hours you know those people have to wait
in line for hours there was a line
to get it done yeah yeah there are
students
[ __ ] if you have a job man if you
have a job and you're you're supposed to
be at work at 9 00 a.m
and you you get to the covet thing at 7
30 and they tell you it's a two and a
half hour line
that's what it is that's the reality and
most of those aren't giving you the
results
immediately not immediately but enough
where you could if you got those results
to say you get those results in 18 hours
say you were going to play in a family
function or something you don't do [ __ ]
like you could
do what i'm saying is like when the
bubble the idea of the bubble first
started starting with the nba
you kind of contributed to that dave did
it well ufc did it first yeah they
did it and ufc did it first but he
always thought like oh my god
you don't have to be a millionaire to
create a safe bubble for you and your
family your friends
right no you can do it now easier than
ever before
but the the problem with the governor
saying is other people will let us make
a bubble and go to work because that's
what they should do
what they could do is what we're doing
here we're just lucky that podcasting is
an essential business i think she's
trying to jump down she's not trying to
kill herself
no i mean she's just looking over the
edge she's
my emotional dog i understand all right
listen
if anybody gonna jump it's gonna be me
i'm in tune with her
okay she's the most adorable little dog
i've ever seen i've never seen a little
dog as a puppy
maggie river she's five months old she
knows her biological dad and i'm her new
dad
it was important for me for her to know
her biological dad because i didn't want
her
to come from a place with like mental
issues and [ __ ] i understand she's in
two with her mother she knows her two
her brothers and sisters they have play
dates
she's but she knows she's my my little
[ __ ] right now what kind of dog is she
a chihuahua pit bull uh no
she's part of pitbull that dog don't
look like his party
what kind of people [ __ ] the chihuahua a
toy pitbull oh really yeah
little ones she's toy chihuahua toys toy
pitbulls are cute little dogs
yeah she's ferocious don't let that
[ __ ] sad eyes fool you have you ever
seen a toy pitbull jamie i don't think
so
they're really tiny we know real pit
bulls like the fighting pit bulls they
were like 30 pounds they weren't big
dogs the ones that they bred for
fighting
the smaller ones are the little little
demons i don't even know if i can
remember ever seeing a small
pit bull yeah brian cowan used to have a
small
pitbull it was a tiny one and it was
ferocious that's where he gets his
personality from it's not him
no he bought animals we went to a guy
who raised them for fighting
oh [ __ ] yeah we were like in our 20s
but oh my god look how tiny damn that
little [ __ ] looked tough as [ __ ]
the black one
look at this the black lives matter one
side space
oh my god that's ridiculous that dog is
ridiculous see that's the thing that
they do
they take these dogs but they break
their legs and [ __ ] like that right well
no they just breed them they they do
what's called uh
like they they select right so like a
dog with shorter legs they'll breed with
another dog with shorter legs and
they'll try to select for certain
traits like i used to have a dog that
was from hawaii
and they used him for hog hunting that's
what they use his family for so he had
long ears it was a dog specific
to hawaii yes yeah yeah they they they
breed a lot of pit bulls in hawaii and
one of their jobs because most dogs
do they go get birds what the [ __ ] does
hog hunting okay see
what they do is in the real thick brush
you can't really get to the hogs
like it's hard to shoot them you with a
gun like you're shooting through
hundreds of yards of brush
but the dogs can go in there and get
them and they'll hold them to hold the
pig
so there's a style of that makes the
hunting easy though right
it does except for the dog it's not like
the same kind of hunting because you're
relying 100 on the dogs usually there's
two groups of dogs depending on what
animal you
like if they they hunt mountain lions
these they'll use a certain kind of dog
that'll bathe the dog
right obey the mountain lion and but if
they hunt pigs a lot of times they'll
use an animal that lets you know where
the pig
is and then they release other animals
that hold the pig
so those are the those are the pit bulls
and then you shoot them
well they usually stab them hand like
up yeah it's kind of [ __ ] oh so that
experience is
all about the dog it's the dog is the
one who did it and you just finished the
job
damn it's crazy too there's excuse me
there's there's videos of it of the way
they do it it's like
and i've been asked to go on one of
those hunts i'm like i am not interested
in doing that
what happens when a dog gets old do they
like get new dogs
but this is a this is a thing that
people are doing for two reasons
one for food right because this is the
best way that they can get food
like you can trap this animal and then
that's that's how you're gonna get the
animal
if you just rely on just hunting with
like a rifle or a bow and arrow in
real thick [ __ ] with wild pigs you're
probably gonna go hungry
so so there's that and then the other
thing is these are invasive animals like
they're brought over to hawaii and
they're wild and they have no predators
so they have to kill them they have to
control them so did they bring them up
here to kill
a species or something like i know that
no no they brought them over for food
oh okay like captain cook and those
dudes used to do that [ __ ] they used to
release ghosts i don't know
cook i know captain crunch i know
captain crunch
yeah that's the cat i don't know
delicious stuff yeah um captain hook
was an old pirate right wasn't he cook
cook don't say hook
hook was a pirate too
yeah captain cook uh he used to
go to islands and they would drop off
animals so that the next time they came
around they'd have something to eat yes
they'd leave goats on an island i think
that's how the goats got on galapagos
i think that's how they got on a lot of
islands the these pirates
or sailors would drop these animals off
but meanwhile these animals destroy
ecosystems
yeah but you had some fresh goat when
you have some fresh coat yeah [ __ ] the
rivers
they had a lot of turtles too they they
killed off a lot of sea turtles because
they would take sea turtles and they
would flip them over and put them on
their back and they'd be good for weeks
yep they would eat them because you
don't you don't need any they don't need
anything
like they can survive just on their back
for weeks and weeks and weeks
and you don't have to worry about
refrigeration or them yeah but you can't
tell somebody you're
hunting turtles you're not trying to do
that that's
slow as a [ __ ] if you're like i
[ __ ] stalked this [ __ ] and i followed
this turtle
for three days i think uh they probably
get them on the beach but if you got
them in the water they'd be quick
sea turtles when i was growing up
[ __ ] turtle on the road
and it was always one country
[ __ ] like this he usually was a
mechanic in the neighborhood
and he had like oil up under his hand he
always helped people's baby mothers with
[ __ ] changing their brake pads and
[ __ ]
just one of those grimy dirty
[ __ ]
that eat any type of roadkill and
whenever we
saw a [ __ ] a dear dead turtle or
something we knew that [ __ ] was gonna
be yelling out turtle soup
yeah people that's like turtle soup yeah
i'm not a big fan of it but
i've never had it yeah it seems like it
will probably be an alligator
meaty meaty type of family alligator
tastes good it is
yeah everything tastes good when it
tastes like chicken that's the reference
for any
thing it tastes like chicken yeah i have
frog legs recently they were good
you it's i've had frog legs before but
trying to convince a black person to eat
frog wear
legs is a tough sale that's all order
yeah for to get a black person
to order frog legs off of a menu it's
like getting them to say
i want my steak uh rare
it's always got to be well done you eat
well done no that's what i'm saying i
don't know
but how do you eat your steak medium
medium
yup not medium rare
i don't there's a lot of black people to
watch this [ __ ]
yeah they're gonna be like i'm gonna
tell you when he changed when they
started talking about blue
and rare yeah when they was like when
they started talking about blood that's
when he lost the streets right
that i could do medium medium rare i
can't do it i would
i understand i've had it like that but
my preference would be medium yeah
but the average you know circle that i
grew up around
my jiu-jitsu instructor eats it well
done and when he orders it i cringe like
machado well done i go do you know what
that
feeling is for the imagine the chef that
gets the order and says
two well done steaks at table 49 they're
calling them every
[ __ ] racial thing that they can think
of
that's the quickest way to [ __ ] make
somebody order a [ __ ] well done steak
and chicken did not enjoy it not at all
did not like cooking it like that
that's a weird thing like a preference
thing like if you ask people's
preference
like it's not like you just cook it like
if you order chicken they just cook your
chicken
they don't ask you what temperature
you'd like your chicken breast but they
know
yeah well they just cook it right but
even pork chops
same thing right they don't ask you but
with steak they'll give you options well
why the [ __ ] are you giving me an
option if i can't have all done you
should just
have it your way but it's just insulting
it is but it's insulting like give the
opportunity to insult
because they do have that as an option
have you ever been uh a certain way
like judge somebody by the way they
ordered their yeah i do honestly but but
again john jack machado like i said i
have nothing but respect for him
it makes me sad that he likes well done
meat
i know this is going to be bad people
like what type of brother am i but i
took my sister to eat once she ordered a
steak
and she ordered it well done i said i
think you should order something else i
said i'm not
paying for a leather belt wow and i
didn't have to eat this [ __ ]
i wasn't gonna do it i just felt [ __ ]
up when you felt judgy
i didn't feel i was judgy a little judgy
yep i was like let that [ __ ] hood
[ __ ] go is it
but isn't that the only food that we
have that with like cheeseburgers nobody
gives a [ __ ] if somebody says how do you
want your cheeseburger like
well in the black well done in the black
community when you say cheeseburger
for the most part that's going to be
well done yeah black people don't want
to see the pink in it that's right
they want they'll tell you all the pink
out
well you really should with ground beef
see the thing with ground beef is
you don't know what the surface area is
when you're eating ground beef right
they take a cows
whatever and they grind it up the stuff
in the middle
like that could have been on the outside
right so you don't know like
when you get a steak you sear the
outside you cook the outside
there's no room for bacteria anything
that could have grown on the outside is
dead and the inside you don't have to
worry about unless it's rotten
that's why black people get their
[ __ ] hamburgers well done
well that's that's wise we didn't know
it but that's just what it was for
hamburgers
you don't want to get food poisoning
right yeah hamburgers unless you
are right there when they grind it or
you go to a top shelf restaurant where
they literally
they'll take a piece of chuck roast and
they'll grow or even flame and yawn
like some of them do it with like uh if
you get a burger that's ground out of
philly
young you're in the right neighborhood
you're in the right neighborhood they
usually add fat to it believe it or not
to make it juicy yeah to make it juicier
what is it with white people with blood
though
i don't know i mean like like
i know this white people get a kick out
of like the rarest they can order their
steak like the blood part of it like
yeah you know what rare is weird when
somebody orders rare or you know what
blue
you bit you proud of the blood joe no
every time you post the elk picture
it's like you you can't just show the
meat
you want [ __ ] to see the knife
and you do your picture joe
it's it's like you waited for the blood
to sweat at a certain temperature you
know when it looks the bloodiest
and that's the shot what i'm trying to
do what i'm trying to do is show that
it's cooked perfectly
that's medium rare with respect for the
meat when i do it i use a thermometer i
mean i do it nice and slow
and i know you know how to cook don't
get wait wait a minute don't get me
crazy
wait a minute just trying to explain
something wait a minute joe what
you're a man of wilderness yes right
and all that you're well respected right
look at that though yeah look at that
joe look at that perfect
look at that that's perfect it doesn't
get better than that
but you're proud of the color of it
because it's perfect
it's perfectly cooked but it looks bl
it's like
what is it it's elk that's elk
that's super athlete i argued with
someone because i told them that you
like elk and i could make elk
and they were like this but they're like
papa makes it
the last time i spoke to you about uh me
cooking
you were very condescending that's not
true yes you were you're making no i
said it the same way i said you got shot
no okay i said you can cook
yeah and you're it's not condescending
it is but the way
with that the way you looked at me you
looked me up and down you judge me
that's the difference joe that's the
jiffers what i said i could cook
elky let me see what i've heard let me
tell you whatever i heard you cook
really well
i heard you have amazing barbecue skills
that could be quite borderline quite a
few people that could be borderline
racist
that could be borderline you said
barbecue
you like i said barbecue is one of the
most complex forms of cooking i know but
you guys
are careful you're doing it slow too
much you [ __ ] it up too little you don't
do it right and then you it's hard to
put it back on
because it hasn't been sitting at the
same temperature the entire time that's
the
art of barbecuing but when i hit
barbecue i think about the barbecue i
understand like the black barbecue i
understand
like the frankie beverly and the whole
thing it's a whole production not just
one piece of barbecue that's what
barbecue in texas is mostly white people
i think
and i you know my own personal
experiences i will say this
white people can [ __ ] smoke some meat
they know how to do it here i'll tell
you that
daddy when i first got i think it's a
place called blacks i don't know if you
found the favorite terry blacks
phenomenal didn't that that franchise
didn't they break up like
yes they broke up they used to be with
the family and then the the
sons started on their own started
playing literally they had some issues
i don't want to air their dirty laundry
on the podcast right
but uh the science somebody stole it
something happened
something happened somebody gave up the
secret these pla people terry black's in
town has only been open
since 2014 i believe and it it feels
like a place has been around 100 years i
mean they got it
dialed in that barbecue's off the hook
think about it they have to have it
dialed in if if they came up
generations and generations yeah they're
just putting whatever the recipe is
whatever the love is i know they make
their own
they make their own smokers they use
giant propane tanks
and they make their own smokers oh maybe
that's what i enjoy
next level yeah white people level of
barbecuing when they start
doing the machines and i should say they
hire someone to make their smokers
but they get this dude to make the
smokers out of propane tanks they're not
buying like a big commercial smoker
they're having this commercial smoker
made they give us a game bro
they did an amazing job they wanted it
to their specifications and those
those uh propane tanks are thick as [ __ ]
it's heavy duty
man where's the wood well you cook with
wood
the wood is an offset you know those
smokers work right so you have an office
a firebox the firebox is over on the
side
and they're constantly checking the
temperature and opening the flues
make sure it's at a perfect temperature
and then you got the smoker which is off
to the side
and they're moving meat around because
it's hotter where the air comes right
out
but they've got the really well ins oh
my god they got it dialed in their
brisket is ridiculous it's so
good that's the what i'm talking about
that [ __ ] melts the amount and it's
don't come off bloody like that it's a
different kind of animal
that's that's that's elk i mean you
could have elk and you could do it that
way they cook the neck meat that way my
friend john dudley
wearing elk yeah neck meat because the
neck meat is very strong and dense
because elk has giant antlers right so
elk's
carrot it's like it's doing weights with
it but elk doesn't have no fatty it's no
fat no fat
no fat no fat there's a little bit of
fat on the outside of them but there's
no fat in the meat at all it's a totally
different thing so you got to kick it
slow
so if it's anything other than that like
medium rare like that it's gonna be
dried out right you want it just cooked
slowly
and seared on the outside so like i take
a totally different approach if i'm
cooking like
a rib eye from a cow versus an elk steak
completely different
way of cooking i know that because you
never post
regular steak pictures it's like i'm i
eat regular no you don't you don't never
you [ __ ] once you
did your [ __ ] first elk your regular
steak pictures
was just dead man well they're not as
interesting to me
regular steak is great i'll cook it i'll
eat it
but the elk is like i have an intimate
relationship with that
everyone knows that of course they do i
mean
even when i tell people i'm gonna do
your show they'll like take a bite of
the elk for me
i'm serious man it's like yo you done
some cool [ __ ] they see you do a lot of
cool [ __ ] but they've never seen you
and you told me do i really want elk and
i was like yeah but um
if i had i was in the hospital
recovering from an injury so i couldn't
get here the way i wanted to
that's a a a lucky injury in the sense
right like i mean
all the things that could have gone
wrong with your thumb not even need
surgery
right able to get the bullet fragments
out i mean that's that's how i run my
life man i try to make it easier as
possible
anybody else could have [ __ ] had this
injury and been [ __ ] up
if the pandemic can't stop me neither
can this [ __ ] thumb man
yeah how does it feel i know it's a
crazy question you get it all the time
from being from a place like you were
saying like what we took advantage of
yeah and one of the things we never took
advantage of stage time because we
always did it but not
having it accessible to you all the time
how does it feel here
with not being able to like you know
what i'm getting ready to go do like
[ __ ] three spots and hammer some [ __ ]
out real quick
well i haven't done that since march you
know
since uh the store closed down there was
no comedy at all in l.a so it was right
it was a whole life shift
um the only time i did it on the road
was july
and in july i did four shows of the
houston improv i had a great [ __ ] day
just left here man great place it was
did you feel
i know this sounds crazy i know we're
gonna get through some mag [ __ ] mask
[ __ ] story whatever but it's a club that
had a certain capacity now they got to
trim it down to meet whatever the
mandated
but people were in there temperature
check they were in there yeah
i know this sounds crazy some people
were mass some people didn't have mass
and i think i'm not mistaken
they sell a ticket as a group right i
don't know if they're doing that now but
they're doing that a lot of places
and it's like you feel good about it
yeah
you know but then it's like people take
away from that feeling
because it's always somebody like
where's the mask where's the mask
right there there are people that are
rightly upset at people taking risks
because those people that do take risks
could then get sick and if they're
irresponsible enough to take a risk and
get sick
they might be irresponsible enough to go
out and mingle with people when they
know they're sick
but some people like that some people
are selfish you know that right
i know that yeah so you have to be and
then they could even give it out when
they don't know they have it
but be asymptomatic but then
at some point don't you have to be
selective
about the people that you and yeah gage
don't you have to be selective on the
chances this is
my frustration i'm not a mask or a
non-masker like people make the argument
but what if i'm in the what if i go to
the grocery store
and i have my mask on and there's this
old lady that doesn't have her mask on
then i don't think you should go places
where
it could be people that don't have their
mask on shouldn't you order online or
something just don't get in that lady's
face and you're gonna be fine it's it's
man i don't think you should tell some
old lady that she has to put a mask on
i ran into old lady at the grocery store
she didn't have a mask on i was like all
right
what are you going to do she's old man i
mean this lady she probably feels
terrible breathing through the mask
feels like she doesn't have much time to
have an asthma attack she had one on but
she was doing this [ __ ]
i got into the argument up yo that chin
i get yelled at i went to a grocery
store i'm getting a couple of items
and i had my [ __ ] mess and joe
when i tell you
the tip of my nose was showing the tip
right here you got mad and this ladies
behind plexiglass
she had sanitizer she was squirting the
registers down every minute she had a
mask
everything and my [ __ ] went right to the
tip of my nose she was like sir
sir sir sir you gotta put your mask on
you gotta put your mask i'm like oh i'm
sorry okay
then i gotta pay i do apple pay but to
get into my phone
you gotta open up the phone with my face
yeah so i put it down
sir i'm sorry i'm like i'm trying to pay
i gotta
log in my face she was like well you
can't do that in here
right you can't use apple pay i can't
show my face to open my phone
you gotta use samsung pay that you let
you use your fingerprint time to switch
to android
i don't have an android i don't have it
that's
very evil for you to end another
i know but i wouldn't talk about your
[ __ ] phone joe why is it evil
because it was the wrong time
[Laughter]
it was the [ __ ] wrong time
and the thing i was making so i had to
hide you guys
this is a sorry this is what i had to do
joe
i had to actually stand
leave the register go to where i could
do outside
yeah show my face over my phone and i
went to pay
and then when that happened i could have
been pissed but i couldn't be like you
know what
i'm just never gonna go to that store
again
well it's just a lady working though
just put the mask over your nose
i'm not gonna put myself in a situation
where i can get frustrated i didn't
it was just for us is there interesting
for apple pay
but you already arguing with her right
is that part of the problem
i never said i was arguing so she was
already telling you put your mask over
your nose
so she was at a heightened state of
awareness frustration
yeah but she also i don't know it was
maybe you know what it was me
i didn't see that energy around anybody
else perfect time to use the black card
i'm not going to do it
it's not it's the nose card she saw your
nose and she's
some people are just like real sticklers
for [ __ ] you know bridget fedesy
no comic from l.a writer she told me she
was walking on one side of the street
there was a guy
across the street on the sidewalk on the
other side yelled at her
put a mask on let me tell you something
this argument i know it's for safety and
everything i know it's for safety
and what the lies we share and all that
but for some people it's a perfect
opportunity
to be an [ __ ] exactly it's like and
that's the like the fine line is like
do you really care about this mass or
you get to either
it's discrimination against mass people
and no no mass people
it's just people have an opportunity to
tell people what to do they get mad they
do yeah they're like
you want to hear to it then they get mad
because you're not listening to the
rules [ __ ] it
right well that's why people are
particularly upset at this gavin newsom
[ __ ]
because he's been the one telling us you
can't have large gatherings for
thanksgiving stay home
social distance wear a mask in between
bites of food
right this guy's been saying all this
[ __ ] and then he's doing now you go see
him eating at a restaurant
so does that mean do we believe
everything's what you got so that's a
perfect example of
you know a lot of things are uh
motivated through politics and looks
you know i'm saying everything you see
not what it's not really
what you think it is so how much uh
how much are you going to put into a
person like what their thoughts
yeah not much what kind of person wants
to do that that's the problem what kind
of person wants to be a governor
they're not normal and you didn't care
until the pandemic
when the pandemic rolled around you
realize oh the mayor matters
it really matters who you know i think a
lot of them like
like have dreams of a certain amount of
fame
and want to be superstars yeah because
even though you say you do it for the
people
you have to be likable or have some type
of personality to connect with these
people
and you're cultivating your act they
have an act too 100
they have an act that's different than
our act our act is to make people laugh
their act is to get people to think that
they're the person who's got the
solution
there's our leader is to lie
yes a hundred percent david you know
what joe we're going through with
all of this [ __ ] and even with this last
election whoever you decided you liked
appreciate whatever it was just so weird
thing going on
it was a weird thing going on and i was
watching one of
david goggins post and i have to say
david gagas
i've never seen nobody have worse feet
than my feet oh
his feet are broken down but he just got
done running 240 miles i know he's going
to defend that i was going to say the
same thing joe
i know you're going to say but what has
he done with your his feet and what have
you done with you
so i know you were going to be like you
know how many mountains those are
[ __ ]
rock blisters yeah legitimate i knew he
was going to say that and that's the
point i was going to make it
there's a point i was going to make he
said
everybody uh yeah jesus christ look at
those big toes yeah those look like
crate like they've been through
that is hilarious those that thing on
the left he showed me that
if you cut out like the right foot's big
toe
that right foot's big toe if you showed
me a photo of that and didn't show me
the rest of his foot i'd be like
that's like a snail or something people
would say if you do that people say that
was my foot that's a mars or
mars rock but like
just zoom in on just the toe don't show
me anything but is right toe
that's a rock from mars that's that's
not real
but that's [ __ ] a lot of miles joe
that's a brain of steel that man has a
brain of steel
that's a lot he he knows how to force
himself to do [ __ ] that hurts
that's what he was saying he said and
then whatever it is he one thing about
him
he always has to remind you that he was
a fat piece of [ __ ] yep
it doesn't like that's got to be fat
must be the number one motivated thing
for that toe
god damn so if you didn't see the rest
of it you'd be like what is that oh
that's a rock somewhere
that's on another planet it's a
satellite
that's a satellite photo white people
y'all groceries
that's a satellite you want to see blood
and plus come out of that [ __ ] i
know you think like
jamie go closer but the point he made
son he said
he said everybody i i used to be a fat
piece of [ __ ]
yeah he was 300 pounds yeah with 300
when i was a piece of [ __ ]
everybody's looking for i need to answer
with this person i need the heirs that
person but [ __ ] it why don't you be the
answer for yourself
yeah that's that's i know people like
well that's easy to say
but why not find
the answers you need in life through
yourself right
and through what you do your hard work
and impr and the type of person and type
of human type of father you are
that's why people like kim are so
important because he'll tell you what
people like him
are so important because he'll tell you
he used to have no discipline
right so like look at him now this is
not something he was really
i gotta interrupt it's afraid he said
this is because i was having coffee with
dave today
and then he said that about you because
i was talking about
uh i can't drink no [ __ ] with my
antibiotics when i got shot and
everything
and then sometimes wait we talked about
you and then and
that's what he said he said i [ __ ]
love and respect his discipline
i do have some of that yeah but i'm lazy
too man i force myself in all the stuff
that i do
yeah but you get challenged by something
though something kicks you in the ass
yeah well
i don't i don't like falling
i don't like not doing what i'm supposed
to do so i forced myself to do what i'm
supposed to do but it's never easy it's
not easy
you know it's like i always would think
of disciplined people as being
like uh there was no wavering they just
got up and did it but that's the other
thing goggins tells you
you know sometimes i'll stare at my
shoes for 30 [ __ ] minutes
before i put them [ __ ] on
yeah cause you want to get rid of look
at the dumb ugly ass
goddamn son goddamn that's not what he's
talking about though he's talking about
i just i opened up my own store right
and after i just saw david garga's feet
you got to help me get that look at that
[ __ ] i know we sold candles
no son you don't know about that yo son
that is joe put a little on your hand
please put a little on your hand
it smells good that [ __ ] is vegan it's
all natural it's
fire son hmm that's what he can watch
what i say son
watch what i say nice watch how long
that [ __ ] lasts yo
okay it feels good i know it sounds
weird look at that [ __ ] smells good
i just got this [ __ ] raw edge the
ingredients are all on the back i know
you don't got your glass you have to
read it
but it's like type of oils and coconuts
i've never heard of in my life coconut
coconut or google all the black nuts
cbd son feel me i don't know what this
stuff is
we're not mongongo oil google it
googling
and mad rich plant butters good man
yo you laughing son you're laughing but
that [ __ ] is
fire son i'm just laughing erica
do put that [ __ ] on right i love it eric
about do put that shirt no that's you
son oh thank you
listen every eric about badu put that on
son
and she started rubbing herself real
real slow she hadn't been on a big
pandemic in a while
and she was like um she was like is it
edible
wow she really high
are you disrespecting my product or you
know if i was thinking about taking
cream and eating it i'd probably have to
be pretty high um
certain people react to things
differently joe it does smell like food
though
it smells like a delicious but wait but
wait to it's like it's like
food it's like food for your your but
your body is eating right now
and 100 milligrams of cbd
yup look at that mango oil there it is
right there
cocoa butter we got all the nuts look at
this when did you start this business
how long i started
i've been working on the formula for two
years scroll down look at that
i know that's my why does it say too
classy
because that's fulfilling ashy to classy
that's the feeling you have
look at that i like the sparkle the
thing about it joe
i've been ashy my whole life right you
know that everybody know it
and for years people like you should do
lotion you should do lotion i'm like man
it's
it's kind of corny i mean it could be a
the novelty b
could be funny yo she larry got his own
lotion
and i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] then i met
with this young lady and she's like a
chemist when it comes to this lotion
[ __ ]
and we started working on it and then
when i when i finally
tried what was the end product i was
like this [ __ ] really work
like it really works and it's good it
sounds like it's good for your muscles
too if it's because
it's good for everything your hands are
going to thank me later i believe it
what is the name of the website donald
rawlings that's where you can get it
okay
this is one thing that came out of this
not just for me joe for a lot of people
think about this a person that makes
their money
on the road a road a real road coming
this happened to me
95 percent of the money that i make is
on the road
95 of the shows i had are done
so only thing i have from what i usually
make is that five percent and i didn't
enough for [ __ ]
right and even though you could have
some money stacked up or whatever you
still gotta
you gotta ask yourself what the [ __ ] is
gonna be the pivot i don't think the
pivot's gonna come for a long time
either
in terms of us being able to get back to
work no no no we about to go
next summer next summer you think joe
donnell i'm not trying to say i don't
believe in corona
right now but we are on the track
of not just deadness [ __ ] but being able
to have it under control
we're about to get to the point where
people are going to uh have more social
security
you know what i'm saying just think
about think about the progress we made
in a year from
when this [ __ ] first happened you take a
corona test you had to wait like seven
days
right think about it when we first went
first hit we had like oh my god it was
so scary so scary
and then all these ventilators
ventilates ventilators but if you know
now since when the pandemic started yeah
we still losing people
but you don't hear that ventilator talk
too much no more well ventilators are
actually a bad idea now they realize my
point you know what i'm saying
i figured out a lot i did a whole
podcast yesterday on covid with uh
nicholas christakis
from yale cover [ __ ] he believes that
is a real problem yeah for sure you
don't i believe it but i believe it's
controlled
controllable it is controllable um
i think there's it's a multi-faceted
problem and i think we're only
handling one aspect of it which is keep
people from working
keep people home keep people away from
people no you can't do you're treating
people like their children
you got this is what you got to do you
got to let them go outside that's what
you got to do
we're going to have more creative ways
to make money like yeah think about the
comedy scene
when we thought like the only place to
tell jokes was on the stage
and i was i had some resentment towards
some of those
outdoor events the parking lot [ __ ]
first time i saw one of those
parking lot shows with horns i was like
never give a heckler
an instrument to [ __ ] your show
like there's no way i'm gonna these
[ __ ] don't like me there's no
way i'm gonna be
yeah but people are happy to be out man
it's a different experience
that's and then the point i always make
is like
you you could suppress people you can
call them down for a certain amount of
time
period time but after a while you're
gonna have to figure something out my
point i was gonna make
something they're only looking at one
side of it they're not looking at
telling people how to be healthy
there's no talk about that [ __ ] yes
[ __ ]
that's what's up right son you're a
strong [ __ ]
all your [ __ ] are strong jamie might
be the least strong out of everybody
excuse me
stop just saying like man
jamie i'm not saying you not strong son
i know that's what you just said though
yeah but you're completely like tony i'm
just saying yeah okay
or red band oh yeah i didn't forget
about it yeah you listen
he's got a oh yeah he's got a deadly
three-pointer and he runs
like jamie's in shape that's black shape
that's possible that's black people's
shape
he does pull ups that's black people
shape run play basketball and pull ups
and push ups you do like the jail work
outside jamie's actually in good shape i
know i believe i'm sorry james i didn't
mean to offend you
i get it he's back
dude it's impressive like rain man [ __ ]
no no
no you can't dunk working on that [ __ ]
he's hitting three-pointer after
three-pointer like rain man
there's something weird about him like
he's got like he might he might have a
wire crossed in his brain
i didn't know you was nice what i'm
saying is to go back to your point joe
is everybody's talking about the end of
corona
like don lemon man don lemon man
ah dawn limit so four years
for four years straight he complained he
was mad at donald trump for four [ __ ]
years yeah
four years and i was like man if donald
trump wins his election
don lemon is gonna jump off the cnn
building do you remember all their faces
when he won last time
when they won in 2016 they were all so
depressed yeah
tapper and all those people on tv just
like [ __ ] i can't believe this
yeah
but here's the thing joe i'm like i
don't think you're supposed to do that
if you're doing the news you're doing
commentary you can do that
i think if you're doing the news you're
supposed to say the news joe let us
figure it out
joe donald joe that's why
i do subscribe to notion that fake news
like to be honest it's all fake
it's all of them are fake it's
all fake and this is what i did what i
keep on telling people is like
how i know you're upset but when you're
like you you're it's all personal
like everything history to the heart
like well that's where it gets weird
those two guys
chris cuomo and don lemon both of them
they do this editorializing
and this like it's it's almost like
they're doing a podcast and their
opinion is all in it
and their opinions in it but it's also
it's on the other side too but it's
scripted
yeah and they're doing it on a news
channel there's a lot going on there
but that's why if you don't here's
another thing about the media if you
didn't understand whatever party you
agree with whatever that if you don't
understand
how easy it is to manipulate the media
joke
it is so so simple to manipulate the
media
to manipulate the media and the people
to listen to it well that's what
manipulate people what do you mean by
manipulate the media
but like you could create stories
you could create stories you could make
things happen
i got shot [ __ ] i see i got shot my
[ __ ] thumb that's what i heard
and a lot of people don't believe me
well i believe you
i don't believe that you believe me
[Laughter]
that's what i believe [ __ ]
that's not convincing but the point i'm
making is
like when i got when i first got shot
joe
i posted on instagram i didn't want to
post an instagram because i know
that i didn't want to get no war in the
streets going on people like going out
looking for the person who shot me my
thumb
so i kept it to myself it didn't really
bring it to me people's attention i
posted one picture of me in the hospital
everybody's like you okay you okay they
don't know
how what i got shot for but they're just
they instantly got connected to that
story
did you ever think of not posting it
i did what made you decide to post it
the world needs to know the world need
to know some of the gigs i had to
postpone when i was
locker shot up not locked up and you
know what i'm saying it's like yeah
i wasn't ready to share to the world
then i didn't know how my friends were
going to take it
okay then i wanted to be transparent to
be honest i let them know i got shot
that's what i did
you know i see you feel like
you still don't believe me i do believe
you i think you're just looking for a
very specific reaction from me
i gave that up a long time ago i gave up
i was like whatever that was what made
me nervous the first time i came up
like what the [ __ ] do i say say what you
say [ __ ] don't try to
all right i'm here you are here but
are you thinking about bailing out la
yet um
i think so yeah a lot of people are the
reason
that we've started feeling um
when we don't well you don't really need
hollywood like that
you know i don't think anybody needs it
anymore some people thought they did
you're right some people thought they
did they thought it was like you had to
be here every night
i thought i needed to be there for a
long time and then once
what happened this situation then you
realize oh what can i do you like wait a
minute
i really can make my own community yes
i can make my own community not only
that you get connected to all the other
communities
like and all the other podcasts we all
help each other we're all together
i will say one with one thing white
people do when it comes to podcast they
support each other
yeah we support each other but you know
what man that's a new thing because in
radio it was the opposite when they had
radio they'd attack each other like i
remember opium anthony was always at war
with howard stern and
you know jay leno was always at war with
uh all the other
late-night talk show hosts and but did
you think that that made people engaged
do you think that made people engage
with their platforms no no no they were
just
they were just scared because they only
had a like
back in the day when you were on
television or the radio you had a very
specific time slot you had 6 a.m
day party to 10 a.m right and other
people are also
on at 6 00 a.m to 10 a.m and no one's
recording anything so you have to listen
to it live
television i was a part of that i don't
know if you i was a part of
when hot 97 was the biggest in urban
radio new york was the biggest
and then i was i was doing radio when
power 105
came and became a competitor they had no
competition at first
you know it was just them then they got
challenged and that would
that's what made for interesting
interesting
[ __ ] between both of them is like yeah
we talk [ __ ] about
97.1 97.5 then 105 then you start
listening to both of them to see what
[ __ ] they're talking
you could do that if you're them or you
could listen
and if you'd like it tell people it's
good that's what podcasters do
like if i'm listening to your show i'll
tell people donald rawlings shows
hilarious
or listen to this guy or listen to her
listen to what i'll tell people people i
don't even [ __ ] know man i tell
people about podcasts that i listen to
from npr or uh [ __ ] radio lab what
i always tell people because i'm
interested in cool [ __ ] i wanna know
about cool [ __ ]
and if i find cool [ __ ] i wanna tell
other people about cool [ __ ] that's cool
but they they're worried about if they
talk about something else it's going to
take opinions
it's going to take attention away from
them that's what's called famine
thinking you can never
famine famine famine feast or famine i'm
a feast thinker
i always think there's enough for
everybody everybody come aboard i want
everybody to be happy i want everybody
to make money i want everybody to be
famous i want everybody to be happy
i want them to be fulfilled i don't want
to be
the man that that idea of being the man
is to me is ridiculous
that's your idea but on the outside when
you do stuff like that for some people
in their perception of you
that's what makes you demand that's what
makes you if you able to inspire and
motivate
that's what makes you demand that you
know you say you know well i'm happy
if that's the case that people think
that way but i know it i'm in a position
to be generous
so they know it they even hold it
against you too it feels good to be
generous
but they hold it against me who hears it
against me people that don't like me
they hold it against you that i have
that i have you on no
people that don't like me they'll say
they hold it against me because you did
like you
oh because like there is a podcast
jamie jamie is that what he talked about
no what are you talking about no they'll
tell you don't like you don't know you
yeah but like some people they told me
they wasn't going to like you
anymore because you liked me good luck
if that's what they said you are
they said they wasn't going to like you
because you didn't but that's ridiculous
anybody who thinks like that is out of
their [ __ ] mind they was like normal
they were saying [ __ ] like this and i
don't read the comments joe
they were saying [ __ ] like this this
[ __ ] like well joe was right up to this
point
yo they like you had a track record like
yeah i believed everything
said until he got loudmouth up there
here's the thing i don't think anybody
will ever understand the camaraderie
that we all have
right comics have it's a different world
but the podcast world is totally
different y'all [ __ ]
yo y'all [ __ ] it's just like
but
man the podcast world is so [ __ ] dope
and the podcast world was ready for the
pandemic yeah
the podcast people was like this what
pandemic i get to spend more time with
my kids i get more time with my kids
and you get to spend more time doing
podcasts because everybody's free
even if you have to do those stupid zoom
podcasts you're still spending more time
doing podcasts
yeah but it's like you figured out like
they knew it was going to happen before
it [ __ ] happened
i came in write it to her i think i came
in right at the right time
i don't think they knew it was going to
happen before it happened but i think
they got lucky
they got lucky that they were look man
back when i was uh just
dependent upon hollywood and giggs i'd
be [ __ ] right now
i'd have no income coming in but you saw
the future too son
you tried i said this to you before like
when you hear like joe roger you hear
about this spotify deal and you hear
about all this type of [ __ ] blah blah
blah blah blah
and then you what you don't understand
like i said joe
everybody wants to be you right now but
nobody wants to be you when people were
saying no and equipment was breaking
down and we didn't know if we was going
to do it
you know thing is i never i didn't think
about it that way i didn't think like i
know this is going to blow up
i thought i like doing this i'm going to
keep doing it so you just
continue to have fun i just do what i
like right all the [ __ ] that i do if you
think about it i just do what i like
whether it's stand-up comedy
or whether it's ufc commentary or
whether it's doing a podcast i do what i
like
i do what i like i don't think oh if i
do this it's going to be huge
i just do what i like that's the most
empowering thing that is so hard
that's the most empowering thing that is
so hard for people
to feel comfortable enough to do it it's
what they're like because the tournament
turning into well this [ __ ] says
[ __ ] [ __ ] all the time you know what
i'm saying they haven't figured out a
way to
get a w-9 or anything for it you know
get they get nervous about the future
too
you gotta you gotta have enough
confidence in yourself to take chances
do you think
that there are a lot of [ __ ] out here
there's a lot of posters is our country
[ __ ] our country has a lot of [ __ ] in
it
because it's too easy to get by and it's
human nature
to become soft when when things are easy
and when
you're in any sign of any kind of
struggle whatsoever that's when the real
[ __ ] emerge
because they can't
because they fall apart any adversity at
all
anything but this is beyond that now
because it's not beyond that now joe the
reason was be on that this is the thing
that this is
a personality trait or just as a side of
not to say that um i'm a fan of donald
trump or anything
but it was certain things that i could
understand where the thought comes from
but how you articulate to people is all
[ __ ] up
the way he articulated to people is it's
like certainly terrible
certain people need filters certain
people need like kanye west needs
interpreter you know what he needed he
needed a coach because someone coached
him for that second biden debate
right if you watch that second biden
debate he was calm and cool let biden
work himself
up and stammer and lie about [ __ ] and he
treat he had still attacked him but he
attacked him in a different way
the first time he did it he was
obnoxious he kept talking over him he
didn't let him talk he was ridiculous
everybody wanted to shut his mic off but
then someone must have coached him for
this
or he realized himself man i'm gonna
take a different approach i'm gonna tell
you something the difference
i'm gonna tell you something different
whatever numbers
you say the loser of this election still
won
breaking the record i know he's not
crazy second place still was
second place would be first place any
other time
in history it would have [ __ ] on
everything that's nuts it shows
everybody realize it's important to find
when you when you realize that a guy
like donald trump can become president
you realize oh my god
it's actually important to vote yo bro
you know it has to until you see those
numbers
yo it was like it was crazy
it was like certain places separated by
five thousand votes i know ten thousand
votes yeah it's tight
and you could say you could make
anything you can make an argument you
could it went either way
here's a situation man
donald trump
let it be known that
he didn't give a [ __ ] about anybody but
his base yeah pretty much that's it
and i'm not saying if it's a numbers
game
understand that like there's a certain
amount of people to help you will help
you get elected
there's a certain amount of people
that's why you have strategists and [ __ ]
they'll be like
if we do this we get these robocalls
here and everything you know it's a
science to that
there's certain people that can help you
get there well if he
but he never made no like if he softened
his approach up
i think the base would not have
appreciated it
the numbers it's like love him or hate
him it's very polarized and for to hate
him works for
right for a situation whereas biden i
don't think people love biden
something has to be i don't think they
dislike it but they hate trump
the people that voted for biden hate
trump most of them or just feel like we
just can't do this anymore
that's the people that vote voted for
biden hate trump but they're not excited
about him the way they're excited about
obama or excited about clinton
or excited about a million other
presidents in the past
not a million yeah but for the most part
every time it switches over it's because
somebody goes totally opposite of what
was going on
yeah there's a little bit of that but
it's it's usually [ __ ] you know
it's [ __ ] man but i'm like man these
old stories
these old stories that they're repeating
over and over again biden is filling up
his cabinet with all these
billionaire uh hedge fund people's uh
like not hedge fund people do you think
by the environment
like the the guy that is involved in an
environmental
he just just hired some guy the people
were upset about i don't know
what color is i was reading about the
important environmental advisor
that's important to me because he that's
important work for a [ __ ] oil company
the black part is important to me
an environmental advisor was taking
money from fossil fuel companies they're
like hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
this guy has ties to fossil fuels and
you're doing something with him that
involves the environment
there could be a conflict of interest
that's what i'm saying yeah if he's a
black guy okay
yeah i could find that we'll find out
right now i bet they probably
listen this is i i think they're
probably going to hire a lot of
republicans
that's what they did they already
started black guys they're gonna they're
gonna hire a lot of people that want to
uh listen and in their defense they
probably think some
radical uh things need to be done to
kick start the
the economy right now i agree but i
don't know how they're gonna be able to
work together
i think they're all dirty bro they all
work together here he goes uh biden just
appointed his climax man yes told you
son
it's a fossil fuel industry ally
black yeah there he is black look at
black as [ __ ]
that's all i need joe there you go he uh
raked in big money from
fossil fuel industry while waiting to
help oil and gas come or voting rather
to help oil and gas companies look how
he's greeting him is different look he's
it's like
knuckles hey fella my [ __ ]
there's a video of um
lindsey graham and uh kamala harris fist
bumping each other
it's adorable commoner reaching across
the aisle that that was a good move he's
walking by
fist bumps well she's the only good move
she's strong
you know she was a district attorney she
got some questionable arrests on her
there's some [ __ ] that she did
imprisoning people and keeping them in
prison to
use them as to fight wildfires and [ __ ]
but i
uh in my community i've heard people
talk about her and everything like
wonder what she
uh you you have trust in her you believe
in her
what i did believe in was when she got
elected to be the first female vice
president first black
like president within a couple of days
the commercials
i've seen on different urban platforms
or just period
it's been you see a little black girl
right looking up to something mm-hmm
you know we see that shadow with her
standing there and little black girls in
the shadow
black girls in shadow but the little
girls are just showing it's like this
they feel yeah they feel black girl joy
they see something
that's she also you know she didn't i
know she put me
just but she didn't do just bad things
she did a lot of good things
she she prosecuted a lot of child sex
predators a lot of pieces of [ __ ]
a lot of bad people she wasn't just
situations where people should have been
let out of jail weren't but there's also
like this is the thing that we have to
realize when it comes to district
attorneys and just attorneys and
prosecutors and defense attorneys in
general they're trying to win a game
and it gets dirty when i tell you what
they're trying to process people
you haven't yet but you i'm sure you
will sorry but when someone you're
trying to drive
a few people or defend people the people
defend people they know are [ __ ]
guilty
and they'll keep [ __ ] from the
prosecution even though they know
they're defending a guilty person they
do it all the time so
people prosecute people that they're not
sure are guilty
and they'll pretend they're sure that
that person's guilty because they want
to win
and they'll withhold information that
could potentially exonerate that person
because they're playing a game when you
let people play a game anytime you let
people play game and someone's trying to
win
they cheat they try to figure out a way
to do better
than you with with influence by
withholding things by holding things
back they know this judge
they're tight with this lawyer right
they try to win a game you've made it a
game
so you got a prosecutor and you got a
defense attorney so you got two
competing forces
you're always going to have lies 100
because people play games
so that was the business she's in her
saying
business that's her business that's her
business
and they are a business of words like
you're saying there's no first there's
some laws how do i win particularly laws
but laws are the word how do i win with
these words right here right
no matter what you think how do i win
with this come on
kamala you know that's not right we're
not talking about right
we're talking about what we could prove
and that's what lord's all about
right well that is if you are a defense
attorney that's your job
is to protect somebody um and try to get
them off even if they might be guilty
and if you're a prosecutor your job is
to prosecute somebody you're not your
job is not to go hey we might be wrong
your job is not to go hey let's look but
the shady [ __ ]
is when you don't play by the rules and
you withhold information
or uh or withhold evidence and people
have done that in the past and that's
when things get real squirrelly because
like okay now
you're not playing the game you're using
your unfair advantage but nothing's
surprising
no no it doesn't surprise me but what
i'm saying is it doesn't make a person
all bad
right she's not all bad like she's done
a lot of very good things and i read an
article about all the different things
she did
including the different things that she
did that a lot of people thought were
bad
like moms threatening moms with uh they
would go to jail if their son was truant
but it turns out no one ever went to
jail it was a threat and obviously it's
terrifying to be a single mom and think
you might get put in jail because your
son
is just running around and doesn't show
up at school because you work two jobs
trying to put food on the table
but nobody ever actually did get
arrested and got wanted yeah because
it's gonna be too hard to prove that
[ __ ] man and some people
and in some cases some people aren't i
don't know if this was case some people
are too lazy in certain situations too
well i'm saying it's it's not a good
idea to threaten a mother
because she's a single mom trying to get
by and her son is not going to school
it's not good to threaten her with jail
time
but sometimes people stop to make
decisions yeah sometimes
people make decisions like drastic
decisions like that and maybe
at the time they had a perspective
that's different than the perspective
that they have now
it's called evolution i want everybody
to have look
i want them to have a clean slate biden
harrison in there now
i think clean slate forget about but
let's see what's going to see what they
can do
the best thing to see the people they
put into office all the the cabinet
let's give them a chance we want them to
do well this is what was so [ __ ] up
about trump being in office
so many people wanted him to do well
exactly so many people hated him
they really would rather the country do
bad under him
because if the country was killing it
unto him he's like look it's killing it
i'm the best i told you
that everybody's like [ __ ] right at
least
maybe please even trump supporters go
into this one with a different attitude
let's let's all together say we want the
best
for america what's it what's done is
done the election's over
maybe you were a tulsi gabbard fan like
myself maybe you like bernie sanders
like myself but maybe you like [ __ ]
gosh
i love yang gang i love andrew yang he's
a he's an awesome guy i love a lot of
his ideas
but for now we know where it is it's
biden and harris
let's go but some [ __ ] man [ __ ]
trump trump trump or you got different
level trumpers well there's a lot of
people that think they're so mad as a
[ __ ] that don't want to hear
[ __ ] son part of the problem is he's
telling them that it's a rigged election
he's telling him that's what's so
effective
but part of the problem is all elections
have some corruption they just [ __ ]
do
they've been around for that enough for
you to say [ __ ] when you leaving [ __ ]
i don't think there's did he keep his
secrets and [ __ ] joe
well mike baker who used to be in the
cia was on
mike baker are you a baker his name is
mike baker
he was in the cia and he came on the
podcast recently he was telling me that
even if they did overturn it even if
they did rather
uh like find corruption the amount of
votes you're talking about in most these
states it's not enough
it's not enough not nearly enough but it
would have to be crazy corruption yeah
like he's talking
these people talking about five or six
people bro yeah and that's the petty
[ __ ] no no it's not five or six people
they man
they've got them i think they uncovered
they uncovered
two different things today in i want to
say it's michigan
where they found uh a memory card that
had
more votes for trump than biden but it
still it was close it was like
1 000 for biden and one thousand a few
hundred for trump like four or five
hundred for trump where'd he get the
memory card from son
i do not know come on joe i think
there's a lot of [ __ ] gonna show them
you could have brought up any memory
card so a [ __ ] is gonna get
everyone who's
counting votes got the memory card from
the machines
who told you that story this is in the
news which news outlet
it was in three or four different ones
and they all say the same thing well
they all
said that there was a memory card that
was discovered
and they showed the counts in the memory
card but they've also found like other
ballots that didn't get counted yet
there's just a lot of disarray you're
dealing with human beings
that are counting millions of millions
millions and they're counting a lot of
them just paper
they're getting mail and they're opening
it up and they have to find out what i
didn't understand that's what i
understand joe this was so funny it kind
of like backfired
right that the mailing votes is what
killed trump that's what they're saying
yeah for the most part and the funny
thing about it trump has the type of
following that
he literally could tell him to do
anything they're going to do it he told
[ __ ]
not to mail in yeah but he wanted to
make a point coming in in person
well this is how do you make that joke
answer this question how do you make
that point i understand making that
point when you're not in the middle of a
[ __ ] pandemic
yeah you know what i'm saying like that
that would have been a great argument
in 16. especially for old folks right
for anybody
that wants to participate but the only
thing that would stop them is if they're
going to go outside and risk their lives
right so you're not thinking to give
that person an opportunity to be a part
of it
yeah and that's the part that kind of
[ __ ] it up well i don't know if
he he definitely wanted people to vote
in person but did he ever encourage
people to vote by mail as well or was it
no
he was always saying that mail was going
to get a fraud son
right this whole [ __ ] was crowded i'm
like [ __ ]
duck somebody secret service break the
secret tell this [ __ ]
yo somebody tell this [ __ ] that
the corona is out here
he caught it he knows it was out there
this [ __ ] caught it
yeah right and gave all the secret
service it give away
secret service can't say nothing because
they see your service they got to keep
it a secret
i'm sure they're young and healthy too
they probably shook it off pretty easy
decided people don't know they probably
got the same medicine he got
you know the medicine is probably a lot
of that medicine is called your immune
system being up to par
as much as like everybody's talking
about this [ __ ] it's the lazy route no
one wants to say
just a little bit of that but they also
gave him a bunch of experimental [ __ ]
they gave him these uh this antibiotic
antibody
uh blood transfusion medication they
gave him uh what was it called regeneron
is that what it's called jamie they gave
him uh some other uh
i don't know if it's experimental or if
it's like recent
recently been released they gave him
that that medication they gave him a
steroid
they gave him uh a bunch of different
things all at once so he got a cocktail
[ __ ] that made him feel great i was
giving a slave
not only that how much is that cocktail
that's not no easy
cocktail it's not cheap and uh he wants
that to be able to
be given to everybody but i don't know
if that's feasible at the moment
to make well it's not just to make the
money just to make the doses
like say if they have all that
medication and all the the
all that uh blood antibody medication
and all this different stuff they're
gonna give him the steroids
to make that for 300 million people
that's so many people
so if everybody gets sick you have a
dose if we have one dose for every human
being in this country
even if you have one dose for half you
can get it done if your money is right
you would need 300 million vials of this
[ __ ]
that's so much you're not going to need
all of those and probably more than that
because
they wouldn't even make that files per
person they wouldn't even make that
number for every for everybody to get
one
they would make that number like it's
got to be that number is going to be
broken down by
okay what's the criteria to get this you
know what i'm saying well also it would
be how many people do we really want to
get it to because how many people are
going to be sick at any one given time
it's probably never going to be more
than 25 of the population even if it's
high but even if it comes out joe
[ __ ]
i'm telling you the certain
[ __ ] are not taking that
vaccine for whatever reason
yeah i think black communities [ __ ]
ain't [ __ ] with no vaccine
it's like a iphone so you need the third
one
no black person is going to take it i
think there's a lot of people that are
not going to take it but i think what
they think is
uh herd immunity once we get to 50 of
the people that took it
the virus will probably die off i think
it's going to be in that neighborhood of
50
of the people that had it if they if if
either 50 percent of the people either
have had covid or
have the vaccine for covid they think we
can hit her immunity and
mostly die off but it could always kick
back in again that's what they're
worried about that it's going to be like
the common cold or the flu every year
would you take a vaccine
yeah for sure if it works yeah if it's
been proven that it works and i talk to
doctors and they explain what the
science is and how it works
then i talk to people that have taken it
and they say you know what the side
effects are because
um with the the covid vaccine i think
the side effects are you feel like [ __ ]
for a couple
days who can't deal with feeling like
[ __ ] for a couple years
you can't lose two days yeah um yeah i
would definitely do it if uh i thought
it was safe
um i don't know enough about it right
now to say that i think
i mean that was one of the things that
nicholas christakis was talking about
yesterday he was talking about
the potential dangers of the vaccine and
i appreciate that he brought that up
because it's such a sensitive area for
people
they think that if you think there's a
danger in any kind of vaccine you're
some sort of anti-vaxxer
no there's a potential for danger of any
medication when you're dealing with
mass numbers of human beings if you have
300 million people and you give them
aspirin one i don't know what percentage
but some
people are going to die from aspirin or
they're going to get really sick from
aspirin
it's the same with everything substances
you put in people's bodies everybody
reacts differently people die from
[ __ ] brazil nuts
you know there's something yeah but
[ __ ] want to waste time with
these home remedies and [ __ ] man them
home remedies i mean they're cool for
some people but
eventually man you have to talk to
somebody yeah for sure
if you're if you got a real disease you
know if you
the people that want to cure like cancer
by not going to a doctor like
whoa they can fix it now like
there's a lot of cancers not all of them
of course
but there's a lot of can you're way
better off having cancer now with modern
medicine than you were
having it fifteen twenty years ago all
that
remedy [ __ ] all although like the best
remedy for all this
besides the medicine if you actually get
sick so [ __ ] take care of yourself
right that's what i'm hoping people get
out of this i don't understand why
people
know that yeah i don't understand this
time
i don't understand how you could ignore
that because it's convenient as long as
you're not sick you don't think you're
gonna get sick
right you stay home if you don't have to
go anywhere you just stay home and a lot
of people just
they just stop exercising they stop
eating well they stop drinking water and
they [ __ ] their body up
and then if something does you don't
realize like how much of a difference it
makes
and being healthy and not being healthy
when something hits you a virus hits
your cold hits you
you see like when when i got shot son
there you go
i had to get the iv i had to get the
[ __ ] um the um iv
antibiotics well you guys get ivs all
the time you're always doing uh
vitamin ids on tour right vital flow
vitamin c it's a company
that's such a good move it is when we
did that the first that was the first
time i'd ever done that
well really vitamin iv yeah i mean i'm
maybe i've done it yeah but you got
you wanted hearts oh i'm on it no you
had everything open you was like give me
one right here
you got half your ass outside i'm like
what you got your b12
shot in my ass and i saw your ass i was
sitting right there i'm like
i was like [ __ ] take that [ __ ] across
the street
he had his [ __ ] stomach out with his
ass out i was like
i'm not scared i don't i know you're not
it was like wow
yeah well the the glutathione was
amazing um
um that stuff is great uh the vitamin
drip was amazing
we started getting them uh every week we
had we slacked off though once we got
here to texas we haven't been doing it
in texas
man that [ __ ] i'm telling you
about when i did yellow springs this
summer that was probably
one of the things that um made that uh
experience so amazing is that we were
living in our own bubble
and playing by our own rules and
everybody was having a good time
and it was all productive yeah you know
it worked it worked
you guys put on a lot of shows adult
summer camps
yeah it was like the shows were one
thing
but the thing that was great for me was
just
the whole sense of community you know
what i'm saying like we would have
potlucks and [ __ ] and then
i would have all the housewives of
yellow springs like
ascendant yo them [ __ ] out
there
don't [ __ ] yellow spring chicks
wives they won't get upset with anything
but a casserole dish son
like they was looking for a rachel ray
castro this i had
for like a week they were stalking where
i was living and everything
but the sensor community man is like you
know there's one coffee shop dinos
everybody go there
it's one grocery store it's just one of
everything
that's nice and it was so simple well
that's better
really then this this there's real good
things about cities
but the thing that's missing is that
camaraderie that sense of community
nature yeah city slickers they were
calling me a city slave i saw the videos
of you and the river
you guys yo joe it was the whitest
greatest adventure of the summer
i became the river [ __ ]
right that's the original name i'm
telling you the truth sir but
your children y'all listening so
peaceful i am at peace
listen joe i first what does it say on
the the quote there
forever mood river [ __ ] love the
river
ninjas they do say [ __ ] love me out
there son
all
yo i'm talking about [ __ ] farmers
market [ __ ] i feel like
i understand what you're saying love me
like women with rescue dogs
great picture man jamie look how
peaceful i was son i was a river [ __ ] i
had to change the name
get that picture framed i need that
picture let's uh let's get that picture
printed on
on steel yo who took the photograph
um federico federico did i tag him yeah
where's get a hold of frederico we need
that picture
in the studio yo he's such a talented
[ __ ] producer and everything
beautiful
but that would be a great picture to
frame in here yo
i fell in love joe people think it's the
river
like it's nature are you gonna let me
describe
me yeah yeah
first name we came up with joe it was
really [ __ ] right and i like that for
the streets right
but people's like i don't know if we
could put that on t-shirts
they're looking at it from a marquee
branded boy right and i was like okay
ninja you know what i mean but he's
inspired by the river [ __ ] but ninjas
for tv
there's many layers to the story many
layers to it do you fish
a fish did you go fishing at all when
you guys were down i didn't get a good
chance to go fishing there but this was
me at a river
in um in georgia son changes your mind
right
it's everything changes your mind when
you buy a waterfall you're like oh
there's something about these natural
things like mountains nature [ __ ]
nature [ __ ] nature nature free as [ __ ]
son
yep it's good for you look at me son let
me tell you
i know exactly they said when did i when
did i
turn into a river [ __ ] right they say
when did i turn when do i remember to
change
right it was when
look at that waterfall man that's crazy
yo let me tell you the story son
so when we were out there chappelle's
wife used to
make these events hey it's family walk
day i'm like man [ __ ] that i'm from the
streets i'm not doing all that stupid
[ __ ]
she had all these days like every day
had a goddamn adventure or a start
what's today you gotta look at the
little brochure and [ __ ]
and then one day she did one and was
kayaking
right and i went on his kayak it was me
and my man patrick he's a yellow spring
he's a
net your spring native whatever and we
were going down the river
mad river i had a coyote he had a kayak
we were smoking a joint and we just hear
nature it's like
just straight nature right and then he
said man
you know what this reminds me of he said
this reminds me of
when i was younger building ramps
jumping ramps on my bike
and me uh fishing for crawdads with my
dad
i was like [ __ ] this reminds me of
looking for my dad
his stories these two stories were
totally opposite it represented one
thing for
him memories he had with his dad for me
it represented the memories i didn't
have with my dad
and the memories i wanted to create with
my son you know what i'm saying when i
was out there joe all i think was like
i got to bring this little [ __ ]
to the river to the river
he's got to be out here he's got friends
out there and my son came out there
and the summer was beautiful but one
thing was missing no matter
how you're celebrating in life right if
you're not sharing with your family it
feels weird
yeah you know it's pills like oh man i
don't even know if it's fair for me to
have this much fun and although how
great the summer was going when he came
out he was hanging with me on the river
and [ __ ] man it was like the best
[ __ ] ever son we would skip jamie
know how to skip rocks of course do you
not a skip
yeah it's in the wrist right i was in
the boy scouts
yo don't say you're the boy scouts today
son why they might have played with your
booty holes
yo it's a lot of them man don't tell me
don't be proud of the boys
pick another division sir not the boys
um
nothing never happened to my booty hole
i had a great time
hung out with a bunch of criminals
that's what you're doing boy scout yeah
we were skipping rocks
like yeah yeah i didn't know
it was that much precision
it depends on the rock like you really
want a nice flat rock
nice if you get a flat rock you could do
some wild [ __ ]
when we were going out every day talib
khalid right he thinks he's a river
[ __ ]
right he told us one day i could skip
any rock you know what
he said he said no matter how big it is
i can skip any rock
that doesn't seem likely that's the
[ __ ] brooklyn cockiness he had right
yeah it was just like it was like
the next time we went he wants to
challenge me and rock skipping again
this time this [ __ ] was pulling
rocks out of his shorts
he had rocks with him already he
prepared
joe he came rocks he came with all
perfect flat river rocks
oh that's crazy he didn't bend over is
there a world championship of
rock skipping it seems like people would
take it super seriously i think it would
i think it's something to think i'm
pretty sure it's done so i've never
thought about it to this moment but i'm
sure there's got to be a competition
rock skipping competition and they got
groupie [ __ ]
like yo the girls who it's off season
for bowling
right they go after rock skippers yeah
we we heard you had a 10 skipper last
week
a ted skipper could get you a [ __ ]
son that's going to get you some whop
if you're looking for walk do a or 10
skipper
you know what whop is right i do yeah
who educated you
because i don't think no disrespect to
your hip-hop or whatever
i don't someone introduce you to [ __ ] um
i don't know it might have been jamie
was it you
um could be yeah because of the ben
shapiro video
oh that's right that's right that's
right yeah which was it
because ben shapiro ben shapiro
it was like you know when some people
self-own they don't realize they're
self-owning
right when you know the song's about wet
ass [ __ ] he's like well that sounds
like a gynecological condition
i would and and people like what
but that's not the point i know the
point is but i understand that that's
like
that's an that's i understand this point
that's an abnormal amount of moisture
yes to be able to come up with a whole
song about it
it's like it's a level what do you think
would happen if you came out with a song
called hard ass dick
i want to do it would not be received
that well as
with as minimal controversy as whatever
certain songs got to be answers
right like answers to a song to wear as
[ __ ]
michelle had a song you can't change a
man right
and i flipped it and did a song called
you can't raise a [ __ ]
you can't save a [ __ ] that was the name
of the song can't save a [ __ ] do you
remember when they used to have songs
and then they would have answer songs
and then like
there's been a bunch of those right
where they would someone would have a
song and then someone like
someone would have a response song to
that like um
scrubs yeah they had scrubs was then
they had another one
it was i can't remember but i know just
wasn't i saw you standing in the ring
wasn't there one of those orange juice
jones uh
so when there were an answer if i know
anything orange juice jones
if i know any answer to that i just
immediately told how old i am
to know origins juice jones and how cool
he was
orange juice jones was a [ __ ] that song
was the best at
a time that was an original kind of song
there never been a song that told the
whole story
of getting done wrong like that
especially didn't tell
it in the rain right like everybody
knows that story
but you followed this couple in the rain
yeah and then at the end when he
chopped back yeah that's
he's like go [ __ ] get out of here yeah
just credit cards and everything yeah
that was a song that made people happy
joe i came over here i'm not selling
[ __ ]
[Music]
you got more stuff yup look you remember
this right remember my black ash right
yes all right here that's for real thank
you
we kept the other one in california
because we weren't sure if we're gonna
be going back and forth
yeah you got that one look at this one
right here there's some holes in this
house candle that's for holiday
it's a ho ho ho hos not like h-o-e
there's some hoes in this house candle
that's a yo look at this one though joe
because i fell in love with yellow
spring that's one of my top sellers oh
yellow spring candle
from the streets to the creeks from the
hood to the woods from [ __ ] to oars
from adidas to tiva's son i got a whole
story boom and just for the white chicks
out there cause i got a lot of white
[ __ ] out there now
okay karen candle imagine if your name
was karen
and you were fine for like 30 years joe
there's more
look at this huh that's like i feel like
all of a sudden we turn into the home
shopping network
that's what i wanted to avoid joe but at
the same time at the same time
i opened up an online store son and it's
doing well okay
do you have a website that we could just
put up on the screen instead of like
bringing all these objects out one
after another joe do you call it no
listen oh you have like a little thing
you scan with the phone
you call them objects i don't call it
objects uh
products man give me my candle back what
is it if it's not a product
no just if you don't want them joe i do
you gonna use them i'll definitely use
them
all right i like candles those are good
too and they're
soy too they're soy yeah they're hand
poured and you can have them back i'm
not into
i don't do anything with soy it's a
candle man
don't disrespect that people one day
people get mad at soy
soy is like a political fruit or a
vegetable is it
yeah yeah yeah people call you a soy boy
if you're a republican people call uh
weak men soy boys that's like a it's an
insult
i never knew that soy is one of the rare
foods that's actually attached to being
a [ __ ]
that's a [ __ ] food yeah like if you're
if you're a guy who's really in the soy
and this is not my perspective this is
just i just think it's a [ __ ]
it's a plant it doesn't matter to me
right it's uh isn't that edamame isn't
that soy like when you have edamame
at a japanese restaurant isn't it soy
yes
yeah isn't that is that the case jamie
the first time i ever tried edamame
i was so ghetto did you use the whole
thing yeah and i was like
i was like my throat was killing me son
the best part is the outside
i didn't know anything about it salt and
everything in the outside the sea salt
yeah
some sea salt you have a bowl of just
edamame
it takes away from it you wouldn't even
want it it's the whole process
yeah the whole process of like ripping
the sleeve edamame beans
are whole immature soybeans sometimes
referred to as vegetable vegetable type
soybeans
they're green and different color from
regular soybeans which are typically
light brown tan
or beige yeah so it's the soy i like
edamame
i don't mind soy but a lot of people
think of soy as being like
a [ __ ] food i never knew that i thought
it was a healthy
i mean i knew that it was not the most
masculine food but i thought it was like
you stepped your game up when you
entered the edamame lane it's like oh
[ __ ] this [ __ ] eat edamame
i think there's a reason i think soy
lowers your testosterone
i think there's like estrogen yeah yeah
soy isoflavones can prov
produce estrogen-like activity in the
body mimicking the effects of
natural estrogen yeah but i think you
can grow titties off of soy
not quite but it might feminize you it
might feminize you
plants plants affect your your hormone
production
do you know they they actually develop
testosterone like
synthetic testosterone from wild yams
like plants
yeah from wild wild yams yeah that's how
they that's how uh
they develop some um artificial
testosterone or
exogenous testosterone i don't think
that that would be part of the whole
siteless um cialis and
blue pill era that's a different thing
though that's just blood flow that's
nitrous oxide so why is nobody
promoting wow nitrous oxide nitrous uh
what is what is it nitric nitric oxide
um that's like uh no explode all those
pump things you do when you want to get
jacked when you're lifting weights a lot
of those
those uh supplements they mimic the same
sort of effect just not the same degree
as like finasteride like ad uh like uh
viagra and cialis and [ __ ] like that
but they don't they don't make you have
more testosterone with these
like soybeans and i i think really for
it to affect your hormones
i think it's just like it can it's a fat
it's a possibility
like chemically but in order to actually
do it i think you'd have to eat some
[ __ ] preposterous number of soybeans
i don't think it's like something people
really have to worry about it no i don't
think it's anything
anybody really has to worry about but i
think it's just a stereotype
i didn't even know that the thing was
that's hard for me i didn't even know
the stereotype
yeah they called boys i didn't know that
i thought it was like uh
uh like you you're evolving as a foodie
you know like the first time i had i was
like oh [ __ ] y'all [ __ ] don't know
about the edamames
because i was introduced to somebody
else to it but i didn't know that it
symbolized being a [ __ ]
it doesn't it's silly it's people are
silly it tastes good yeah adam
may taste good if they do it right put a
little chili powder and
salt on the outside i like it with just
sea salt
i like it sea salt too i'm working at a
stadium joe are you really yeah what are
you doing
rfk stadium where's that in washington
d.c
when are you doing that uh uh
thanksgiving weekend
oh [ __ ] it's not the state of it's the
parking lot right
you're doing like an outdoor show i'm
doing an outdoor show just like the the
ones that bert's been doing
yeah but no not at that level yeah i
talked to bird about that shout out to
burt and shout out to the camera bert is
the guy who started it all off people
aren't giving him enough credit he's the
he's the og of drive-thru shows yeah it
was like
it fit right into his whole [ __ ] he
never stopped touring bert toured
through
the entire pandemic doing drive-throughs
and i was saying i was driving is this
like a throwback thursday or whatever he
was like this
and then the name of what was the summer
what was the name of the tour the um hot
summer tour
i'm like this [ __ ] but he
created the bubble and he [ __ ] did it
created a bubble
stayed drunk the entire summer and
enjoyed it had a good time
i'm doing rfk stadium it's the original
um stadium for the uh
for the um washington redskins the
washington redskins used to do that
beautiful but for nine years that was my
uh
traditional show at the dc improv i
would do thanksgiving weekend
it was a good time for me because i got
to see my family i got to work
that's a great club too so great dc that
dc improv is
one of the 10 greatest clubs in the
country and it's been probably the most
consistent for 25 years so good it's
just the perfect size
perfect everything about it's perfect
and they get every year solid
it's i don't even know that a comic can
do bad in terms of ticket sales there
everybody seems to do well at least the
lineup
they have they book good lineups like
when the club's got that much prestige
they've been around that
there's certain clubs like comedy works
where people just trust them you know
uh there's a bunch of helium in philly
people just trust them this is going to
be a good show they're not going to book
any scrubs
right and that's that's how the dc
improv has felt like
they have developed a community a real
and i for nine years i saw my son
from the first time i took him up it was
just him in my arms
and then the next time he was kind of
like crawling there next time he was
walking
then he walked to the stage i had like
four years of
pictures of his growth there and then
because of the pandemic
i thought the weekend was i'm like damn
that blows a tradition
yeah and then they piv they made a pivot
from the dc improv
to partnering up with um dc pull up or
whatever it is
and they're doing the [ __ ] outside
show that's beautiful i like that people
are adapting it's one of the things
you're saying like you started this
business
and bert started doing things outside
and tom segura's doing like these
pay-per-view shows
tom segura and burke crusher are doing
these and and sometimes christina they
switch up back and forth right they're
doing these
crazy live shows i saw they the [ __ ]
that he
sent me i mean i'll show it to you after
the show the things that they can
see during these live shows it's a
hundred percent uncensored
because it's pay-per-view so they don't
have to worry about youtube they don't
have to worry about that just whatever
they are showing the most [ __ ] up
videos i have ever seen in my life
in my life really in my life
like he he sent me three things
yesterday
that changed my idea of what's possible
oh my god yeah you gonna do it
do one of his shows yeah um i would
certainly do it if we were in town
together and he's
you know tom's talking about moving here
if he moves here everybody [ __ ] moving
out here yeah
we got the whole squad coming back here
we're going to open up a club here
i'm down son come on down it's better
here you don't have to pay taxes for
state
people are nicer to the bus they said
the street on the streets they said
on the streets they said joey stupid son
this tree said that [ __ ] said i'm
getting the [ __ ] up out of here son
well i saw the writing on the wall i'm
like they're not going to open up the
clubs if you don't have a comedy club
open i can't stay
if i'm if if the comedy store was open
there would be no reason for me to leave
valley i know
but then at the same the same on the
flip of that
uh just because it's not open it's not
there's no reason for you to
be in that line be that you can create
it well the only time i could create it
though
is in an absence of the club so because
i wouldn't ask people hey leave
la the comedy store is hopping and
killing come to come to austin
but when you can't open they can't
they're not allowing them to open
and it could be years who the [ __ ] knows
now right here we are now eight months
in no one ever we thought it was two
weeks
but do you remember when you thought it
was two weeks two weeks but then again
even moving forward joe
we you gotta remove the possibility of
something taken
you gotta remove yourself from the
possibility of somebody taking something
away from you
and like like that yeah like that like
like what you the way you're thinking
and the way dave has thought throughout
this summer is i was like
yo we really can make this [ __ ] well
also
what we were saying before that we were
all connected to hollywood because we
thought we needed hollywood right
in order to get us on television in
order to pay our bills
we needed to get hired and then once
podcasting came along
i think people realize no you don't you
just need your friends
and you have a bunch of funny friends
and everybody's tight and everybody
tells people hey
go see you know theo vaughn's at this
place go see this guy go see that guy
and we all get along together we don't
need anybody else yo but joe the
toughest part
what did i notice in this podcast world
which
is predominantly white that's the truth
of it you know what i'm saying it's like
there's a lot more white cos podcasters
when it comes that when you say like the
friendship part of making money
they really about that life they really
do it
yeah they really do it they don't talk
about it every one of the guys
that i've done you know from the leah
from
bobby from the whole crew it's never no
oh man
it's like everybody helps everybody yeah
everybody's friendly and there's only a
few people in the podcast world that
don't have friends
they're weirdos i don't know they're out
in the fridges
they're out in the fringes all right
those poor people they they're they
a lot of people go into things with like
a legacy attitude
and the legacy attitude that you know
from radio is to competing against the
other people that are doing the same
thing
right but the podcast world is not like
that but some people are like that like
some people will complain
if a guest is on this podcast and then
on their podcast
they'll complain like you were just on
that podcast now it's going to take away
from people listening to me
i got more [ __ ] to talk about you ain't
got no life well not yo i never
understood that suddenly like oh
i'm like [ __ ] every podcast i go on
it's talking about something else
not only that but if you go on a podcast
and they like you
if you go on a podcast and they like you
and then i hear now you're gonna go on
bobby's podcast i'm gonna watch you on
that podcast too
right because it's not like i'm gonna
like i do one podcast and now i'm out of
time
but i've got more time there's you're
going to have another week is going to
go by where you want something to listen
to
and then more people going to listen to
you on bobbies if they heard you on
somebody else's
and here's the thing joe if you're
interested enough for [ __ ] want
to listen to you
that's it if you could do it the
toughest part this
week literally is i think
the anniversary of the first time i've
ever was on this show
really i think it's this week
jamie's checking i heard those fingers
said my producers don't do that those
[ __ ] look at me right in my face
it is right yeah i guess what was it was
that
were you around before that right
february 19th now you remember before
that one
that before that one no this was the
first one we talked about the rizzo [ __ ]
that
was that that was a year ago this week
yeah that's when november 12th so but
yeah but you've been on
longer yeah yeah but i'm just saying
from the last one
yeah oh yes yeah so i know you guys want
to break down the story it's not that
sentimental but i was just saying i
remember the dates yeah
no i guess what was that and it's been
like
it's been i've been doing it for a year
and it's been um
it's been interesting it happens right
it gets it picks up steam
picks up momentum i see on your
instagram stories you're putting on your
instagram rather you're putting clips up
little assets people excited
yeah yeah but yo you like everything you
said it was like
once i got out of the mode like i'm like
ah this have to be the greatest episode
i'm like wait a minute did i start
looking at the numbers of
the most successful people in the
podcast world this is like episode
1582.
yeah this is the 30 episode anniversary
well you know how goggins tells
everybody he used to be fat
i tell everybody go to episode one it's
[ __ ] terrible right it's terrible
we we didn't even think it was a podcast
we were doing it with uh just answering
questions over twitter and being stupid
while we were high
no one thought it was ever going to be
something that millions of people listen
to
so when we started it out it wasn't
you know there was no expectations now
people have expectations
they went out you realize like how much
money is in it
you see all these people that get big
deals you see all these people that are
you know number one on itunes and number
two on
[ __ ] spotify and you go [ __ ] like
there's a lot going on this is a whole
network that you don't need a lot to get
into
man the number one thing you have to do
and i kept tricking myself
we had talked about it was talking can
you talk
that's ridiculous that you don't think
that you could talk
it's one of the most funny things i've
ever heard
son i mean with no response just like me
talking to myself
that's easy you know what i'm saying
it's like you know i got a better chance
of making a thousand people
left in one person true you know yeah
but it's been a
it's been a great ride man i do
dairy over there julius you know who's
the best at just talking
bill burr that [ __ ] just he
never has a dead moment he will start on
a subject and like you know and then
you know what they want to [ __ ] do
and then i used to be an
hour later he was one of the guys that
had it i was like
what would your style be more like i
just like i don't want to [ __ ] talk
to nobody
i just want to say what i want to
[ __ ] say and [ __ ] you
and then it was like the monday rant or
something yeah monday morning podcast
monday morning podcast and it was just
like
that was like this [ __ ] can talk
[ __ ] for whatever
it's like whatever it's like a dude that
goes
he like wins all the bar fight
conversations
and it's the perfect platform for that
oh for bill it's a perfect platform one
of the things he used to do is he used
to
use his cell phone and this is when oh
god
the early days of the monday morning
podcast i don't know when it started i
bet you it had to be around
2000 um 678
somewhere around there it could be i
don't remember but what i do remember is
that he
he did a bunch of them where he like
left voicemails so he would call himself
or call a service and leave a voicemail
really so he'd be sitting there
at the airport talking [ __ ] about some
dude's haircut
oh yeah i remember those yeah yeah and
then he had somewhere it was just just
him really ranting just yeah
the audio quality was [ __ ] terrible
because he was literally
talking into an old phone at the airport
and then leaving a message somewhere and
that message became the podcast
and you know what and it was hilarious
it didn't even matter the quality of the
sound the
idea was funny just like when i told you
that time when jamie was supposed to
help me produce and then he [ __ ]
reneged on me
right right he got real mad at me
whatever
i remember it's like it was yesterday um
i understand i don't know how those two
are connected but
but bill burr when he when he first
started out like that was literally the
perfect platform for him
in podcasting like he's good at
interviewing people i've been on a show
before
other people have been on the show
before he'll he'll sit and talk to
people he's fine at it but
as far as like ranting he's the best
yeah
yeah but he's also been doing it the
longest you got to think how many
[ __ ] years
he's been doing that podcast where he
just that muscle is
flexed that muscle is tight he doesn't
need like
you can form an opinion but he doesn't
need the response most people
right need the response and the feedback
how how else do you know if you're doing
good or not
yeah he doesn't think about that he's
like and another thing
i was watching seth meyer the other
night and it was a
he was doing this monologue or whatever
and it was going okay
and then um uh he uh
some people in the background were
laughing and you could just see
the posture and everything change once
he got a couple of people laughing it
was like
that's important i heard his netflix
specials good really
yeah yeah i saw a clip on it it did not
look bad it did not look bad when this
is this recent because i know he had one
i want to say his netflix special was at
least a year ago because it was
pre-pandemic for sure i didn't see the
entire thing and
i saw some clips and i was like this is
good delivery
good writing and i'm not i don't know
that seth meyers
like really had a long background stand
up did he
no he had a background doing that show
doing the monologue for the show
but i i i don't think his stand-up was
very good
whoa i thought it was solid did you ever
see it jamie it's
fine it came out the other october you
all right
jesus that's not a good time to be
coffin
it was uh very good into what i saw the
clips i didn't watch the whole thing but
but most of the guys when they um do snl
uh you know there's some people that
have done
talk shows and then tried to do a
stand-up special and they don't really
have the chops for it
but that didn't seem like that with him
yeah he seemed very relaxed
right was kind of peaceful wow well he
probably he probably did the right thing
too he probably hired a bunch of writers
i mean i didn't see all of it maybe
the part that i saw was the only funny
thing i really have no idea a lot of
those guys i guess when they
like when i get to be buried into that
show like that yeah so i don't really
have time to go out and work out and
no it's hard it worked out but if you
could do it like jimmy kimmel could do
stand up for sure
hundred percent jimmy kimmel wanted to
stand up 100 percent he could do it
what do you think about jim carrey on
snl i didn't watch it
none of it nope not one piece of it not
a piece god damn son i got [ __ ] to do
if i'm gonna watch something um i
generally when i get home i like to
watch like
things that have nothing to do what's
going on right now by the end of the day
i don't oh you like documentaries yeah
new netflix special
lets you skip the trump jokes oh you
there's a button you could skip job
jokes
yeah if you're interested on netflix you
could see that's the chunk of stuff
but this is him talking to people so
he's interviewing people this is just an
interview about it
oh interview about it oh okay oh that's
funny
yeah well that's a good move because
people are tired of trump jokes you know
that's one of those
people enough already man i've been
tired of them
and then i'm like they're coming back
around before they're coming to be
frustrated to be frustrated when a dude
is on his way out
you know it doesn't make no sense it's
like he is still getting to you
you know it's just a matter of time if
you want to say
the people the voice of the peoples was
heard it was a close
situation but it is what it is and he's
gone why are you still mad
people have some legitimate gripes and i
understand where they're coming from but
my perspective is
it's not changing anything and it's not
doing you any good
to still be holding on you're if you are
a anti-trump
biden i mean i don't think it's
99 official right i mean they just
haven't said it yet
and they when they say it then he will
be become president
and then kamal harris will be the new
vice president
so concentrate on good votes now
it's over right but people are so
obsessed i heard the [ __ ] the other
day i might have said this earlier
look at mike pence and i'm having a
meeting with no mess man
okay why you still keep getting mad
because this [ __ ] don't have a
mask on
it's got to be something else to talk
about son but this they they want to
talk about negative things that's the
thing
some people get addicted to talking
about negative things and they can't
regroup
even after a victory and now focus on
positive things they want to continue to
focus on negative things
and i can see their perspective too
especially with all these crazy tweets
like i won that election
you know it's all fraud it's all this
it's all that like
man if you've got some real claims and i
don't know what the claims are i haven't
really honestly investigated them but if
you've got some real claims
you got to present the evidence and then
once you present the evidence you say
all the stuff like i got robbed i really
want it
if you want to be in a position where
you're respected
right if you're the president of the
united states this isn't a regular guy
it's not like if you were involved in
some
ridiculous like small neighborhood
election and you were joking around on
twitter i won that [ __ ] election
right
that's that's that's to be expected but
when someone's in a position where
they're
in charge of the nuclear football they
literally
are the commander-in-chief of the
greatest army of the world he's never
known [ __ ]
you're saying [ __ ] like that and firing
people that don't agree with you no
fireman fire [ __ ] did like i
know these other places like what this
would be a great time for
a [ __ ] terrorist attack right now
well one of the guys
he fired what the guy said was he didn't
believe there was widespread voter fraud
he's like you're fired
if you don't believe that you're fired
like this is this is like a madman
the interesting part for me is like
you trying to switch the thoughts
of a person that is a huge trump fan
is a waste of time it's only gonna be
the only thing you're going to be is
frustrated
see here's the thing though i don't know
and this is where it's really important
i don't know
exactly how the election went
down in terms of like was there like
0.01
fraud was was there 0.5 percent for
how much fraud was there we gotta assume
that when there's people counting stuff
there's some [ __ ] going on yeah but
the [ __ ] that's been reported it's
been like still no more
like 40 people bro and then the only
other problem is
that it's all done through these
machines right and then
there's been all these conspiracy
theories
about machines that were supposed to
have been
giving the votes to trump gave those
boats to biden
now i could repeat those things but i
don't know if they're true
but i don't know what i do know is what
i'm saying i do notice it but i know
georgia
i know the [ __ ] pulled all of
envelopes up to the building
and they cut them open and they took a
man by hand
they did them hand by hand yo those
those ones that were recounts or
whatever
those you can't is no machine that it's
hand by hand
right it's [ __ ] probably and how does
that work did they does someone watch
while they do it like do they have a
supervisor
because i would imagine you would want
to have like almost like two people
watch
while one person does it which is so
ridiculous but it seems like you kind of
if you don't trust your view
that's part of the argument that trump's
administration was saying too
was that there were certain counts that
they weren't allowed to observe
they had to be really far away and they
couldn't actually see
listen that sounds like people that like
soybeans so
but that's the first thing is that's a
very soy boy
attitude but what if they're telling the
truth here's the thing i don't know
and you don't know either so if they
were telling the truth and people were
counting votes incorrectly or they find
no evidence of that every time they i
don't think they have either every time
that they
they came out with all these losses and
they're dropping them dropping them
because there's no evidence of it he's
probably made
he's he's had to have made every
argument he can make
no listen i agree with you i agree with
you there's no
evidence that they can present that's
going to show people
right now that there was so much voter
fraud that they got to return
everything and start all over or they
got to give it to trump like i agree
with you i think this is what all these
experts are saying they're all saying
that even if there was
voter fraud it wasn't enough to tilt the
election one way or another but i don't
know
how these machines work so if i'm even
commenting on it
if i'm saying they couldn't have done it
that's ridiculous i'm saying they
must have done it that's just as
ridiculous i really don't know
that's like when you're talking about
voting you're talking about
how many millions of people are voting
and all this
information is coming in and they gotta
sort it out you're gonna have some
mistakes
there's no way around it but the
question is does it
overall balance out or other mistakes
all for one side
if you find out the mistakes are all for
biden then you're gonna go
huh really well who who owns the company
that makes the machines and then how are
they financed and who programmed that
and how are they programmed is it
possible to [ __ ] with the data it is
possible
can you show me how to do it you can do
it you should but so
about the vote everybody wants to know
exactly what happened
i think but very few people that know
exactly what happened
i know i know the machines and all that
type of [ __ ] but when they take the
machines away and they say okay
we're counting these hand by hand the
the the results of that have to be
official
yeah well they definitely like that i
understand like the machines but they
was like
these melon [ __ ] was they
they've had to [ __ ] count every vote
yeah it's a matter of how they're
recording it right you would want to
make sure that everybody recorded it
accurately
i don't know how they do it but i would
imagine
that when i when i was talking to a guy
like mike baker and who's saying that
even if there was fraud
there's not enough fraud to overturn i
would imagine he knows some things
yep i don't i'm a [ __ ] so with me
talking about he wants
we all do that you know we talk about he
won she won and there's no way there was
fraud or it was definitely fraud or
i think trump won by a landslide like
people get
they get real um connected they get real
connected to who's who's winning or
losing this election and i get it
i mean i'm gonna miss donald trump son
yo
he's not going anywhere man tv man i'm
gonna miss him on tv this [ __ ]
tv persona is you know what sucks what
sucks that it's
his tv persona is like he's a tv
[ __ ]
it sucks that it's even possible that
someone could
monkey with an election to the point
where
you change the outcome it sucks that
that's even a thought
that we could get into our head that's
what's
one of the crazy things about people
we're so nuts but that wasn't it
we believe in a side like people that
are good people
will do some shady [ __ ] to have their
candidate win
yeah for sure that's politics
we're so crazy that's politics anything
goes
anything goes yeah so what what bothers
me
and i do think that biden won the
election and i do think that
i mean i think there's probably some
shenanigans but i think the result is
most likely correct but
it bothers me that there's even a
question it bothers me that anyone would
ever think that
anyone could but i think that there's
republicans the democrats could do it
and i think there's democrats that think
republicans can do it and i think
it's it's going to be real hard to 100
trust the election
that's one of the things that's kind of
dangerous about someone
going after it this election is rigged
this election is rigged
when trump is doing that he's
encouraging p and
you know maybe that's a good thing if
they are rigged
because maybe they're going to be able
to figure out how to stop that from
happening in the future
or maybe it's going to erode or maybe
it's going to road people's confidence
in the elections and the more he does it
the more it erodes and more gets
dangerous
there's a real argument for that too but
listen again
i'm i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about man it's
just
i know it's nuts it's nuts that you
would anybody would ever think there'd
be any
voter fraud on either side but we know
that people have done it like that's
apparently how they got
jfk in wasn't there like some crazy
conspiracy about
the mob rigged votes for jfk and that's
how he became
wasn't that a thing jamie yeah i've
heard has that ever been proven
i've heard talks about recently that
they were in such odds with each other
that they would never have helped
him i think he was really at odds with
them afterwards because he didn't
like there was the the the thought was
that was one of the reasons why he was
assassinated
that he kind of doubled back on his
agreement with the mob explanation i
heard they were just helping uh local
politicians
oh he didn't play the streets to the
president well his family were drug
runners
the kennedys were moonshiners and they
made their money
selling bootleg liquor during during the
time where it was illegal they were
basically drug dealers
and then they became this gigantic
political dynasty
they were the trump no not the trump
family but they [ __ ]
they were more gangster than the trump
family really because their their
literal background
was in drug running like bootleg liquor
like moonshot
is drugs that's drug running you just
don't think of it now because
alcohol is legal they were truck runners
yeah
and who had the [ __ ] connected to the
mob and they were connected to the mob
like you don't think they [ __ ] with
some numbers you don't
you don't think there was some
corruption who has the [ __ ] money
i think there's an assumption too that
both sides are going to try to do it
i mean that was why that was uh a water
gate right
the results of this election man it's
going to be interesting to see
can can can biden work with two parties
both parties
i hope so i hope they i i hope they
prove
like the polarization of people that are
opposed
to uh trump being in office and now
they're not republicans and democrats i
hope they work together
yeah man that's what i hope that's what
i help i hope they work together do it
faster biden has done got like a lot of
time
you got to get used to president kamala
that's what you got to get used to
i said it man she's going to be the
first president i
said it that's the position i don't see
how he can do eight years so what if the
economy i don't want to be strong in
four
i think four he's going to keep it
moving man who knows it's a setup i said
it on stage
i said get ready for your first female
black president because this is the
setup for her she certainly could win
she they grooming it she could she
certainly could take over too if he dies
or if
he can't medically continue anymore but
here's another thing you got to think of
they're doing [ __ ] to people that
they're doing some wild [ __ ] in terms of
medicine and regenerative medicine and
stem cells and
they just hook them up to stem cells
every day shoot them up with nad and
vitamin feeds and steroids and growth
hormone
you never know they might keep that
[ __ ] around for a long time how
joseph kennedy made his fortune hint
it was bootlegging no this just wasn't
bootlegging oh it wasn't oh i can't see
the end because of the white shirt
according to the biographer that is a
rumor that
started in the 60s and 70s when they're
trying to figure out who killed jfk and
maybe it was them off because they were
in that business
that sounds like the kennedy family is
trying to cover up their dirty tracks
it's a rumor the [ __ ] out of here nobody
has a rumor about you bootlegging ever
no
i'm just i was looking because i've
heard that too but like
right away okay it's like in the stock
market that well
maybe maybe bootlegging too let's try
another source let's see
uh joseph kennedy was a bootlegger
type that in what well that story is
going to come here the daily beast the
myth of jos
joe kennedy's no so it is a myth i don't
know where i would find the correct
story to
you know i know right like how do you
know who's telling the truth and whether
or not it's a
this big old historical cover-up like if
you were bootlegging how much
information would there be about you
being a bootlegger
unless you got arrested for it for me i
think cops were probably in on
bootlegging back then don't you think
everybody that could make money was
involved with sure everybody what is my
piece
you probably they probably were angry
that the bars were closed too
yeah and then they wanted a couple
bottles give me a cup of bottle come on
so you can do whatever you want to do do
you imagine if that's how we lived right
now if booze was illegal
imagine as much as people drink if you
had to do it all
secret you had to like have a big dude
by the door you'd have a password to get
in
you're always worried about getting
raided by the cops just so you could
have a drink
but people would do it they did it they
did it for years they made organized
crime
that's where like al capone made all of
his money that's that's
yeah that's the argument that's going on
right now with um
with the mexican cartels like the reason
why they're able to make so much money
is because all that stuff's illegal and
they're consuming it in the united
states
so you're playing a stupid game you're
pretending people aren't taking it when
they are
you're making it illegal because you
said they shouldn't do it but you want
to control it
you're just empowering organized crime
and that's what they did with organized
crime in chicago
that's what they did with organized
crime in a lot of areas of this country
where they had that's why they probably
want to position people
that they had influence over to be
politicians
for sure they had so much money and back
then there was no internet nobody knew
what was in your bank account where it
came
bro shut that ding off geez no i was
checking i didn't know oh no
sorry man dude put it put that [ __ ] on
airplane mode what are you doing okay
do you know how to shut off the ding
though come on man stop disrespecting me
but you've done it a few times i don't
understand why it keeps dinging
it won't ding again man all right i'm
sorry man
oh donal donald
you can't say [ __ ] now you don't even
know how to non-ding your phone
just shut the [ __ ] ringer off man
no you gotta flip it up towards you
you're you're keeping it down which is
off man
okay i'm just gonna ding again i'm sorry
man it's gonna ding from beyond the
grave maggie is down here
[Laughter]
she's adorable man um
man what were we just talking about i
don't know
do you remember jamie oh kennedy's being
a bootlegger oh
yeah maybe you were i might be full [ __ ]
uh but we didn't know you for sure
validated the story but it was like
there was just a rumor you know how it
started
right for sure there's a lot of
organized crime money in [ __ ]
bootlegging
that's a fact i'm on antibiotics because
i got shot
yeah you can't drink for how long like
three more days son
refreshing though give your body a
little bit of a break it is but i'm
it is that's it you're looking forward
no no not missing it you know what i'm
saying like after a show
a little shot right well you know i just
got this for all the people that's been
in the streets and got shot
got to get better are you um nervous for
the country
right now are you nervous about the
future no
not at all no i believe that
we always going to find solutions to
stuff like the first thing like you
mentioned about people that need to work
or whatever
the first thing that's going to happen
is there's going to be some type of
stimulus package approved
[ __ ] is going to feel somewhat
security or a little better
if they have some money to be able to do
something but this is just something
that
this is just something that we're going
to get past it's just a
it's a matter of time and with the
vaccine being on board
with them having more ways to test
somebody in a
faster manner they don't cost as much
i think it's going to change people's
attitude the way they feel about certain
things
and things that start turning around i
hope you're right
um my concern really is about how how
hard it's going to be to turn around the
economy with
that many people out of work that's what
my my worry
is so many people are going to be broke
and so many people are going to lose
their houses so many people are going to
get evicted
i just don't know how they stop that and
turn that around when all these jobs are
gone because all these businesses went
under that's what scares me
it's like that this wasn't anticipated
that i think there would have been
another way to do it
you know they certainly didn't lock down
as much out here
not nearly as much and then that's a
good point because i
mean like whatever you worked for
whatever just could be pulled from under
you just like that's the thing about
like you can't
say that the people that are upset today
are soy boys
they can't say that they're all [ __ ]
because there's a lot of people that are
upset through no fault of their own they
lost everything right you could be the
most disciplined guy in the world you
get up early every day you work hard all
day
you you build a business and then all of
a sudden kovid comes around and you know
you find out your margins are a lot
smaller than you thought
well nobody expected it to go eight nine
months right so you're not making any
money for eight nine months and you
can't reopen
there's a lot of businesses like that
there's a lot of bars
there's not enough bailouts there's so
many businesses there's not enough and
they're not going to give it to all
they're not going to give you all you
lost
you're going to lose a tremendous amount
no matter what well there was a lot of
people getting that money that was
[ __ ]
but it was so much goddamn [ __ ]
scandal with them
pba loans and [ __ ] man everybody was
grabbing them [ __ ]
you know they'll find money then you got
to pay it back
i hope we figure out a way to
make this uh make this economy bounce
back and
but i say we when i say we i mean people
way smarter than me
i hope i hope somebody figures it out
about my son had the best life he can
have yeah well i hope so too
you know what i'm saying like i think
that
it's gonna get we're gonna just start
people gonna be concerned about people
close to them and their family
and how that situation is going yeah
i mean everybody hopes that the next
person that gets in office is gonna nail
it
everybody hopes the next person that
gets an office is gonna fix all our
problems
we gotta change the way we communicate
with each other that's a big that's a
big one
everybody's locked in this trap of uh
us versus them of red versus blue
of like what whatever the the trap is
like
whatever your particular trap is there's
men versus women traps
there's people get crazy with being
tribal and being on a [ __ ] team
we're supposed to be one team supposed
to be united states of america
if we differ on small things like
immigration
or things like
financial issues or how to use uh
taxes and the most important thing is
that
we all want what's best for the country
we all want the country to do well you
want to thank people
you want to that's the that's how you
want people to feel
that's what drove me the most crazy
about trump being president i felt like
it was the first time i could
ever remember where people wanted things
to be
bad so that he would be a bad president
so that i mean i guess they probably did
with obama too
they wanted things to go bad so they
could blame it on him like they would
rather
have something to blame on him than to
have everything go well like if you
asked a hardcore trump hater
would you rather this would be a good
question would you rather
the economy become the greatest economy
the world has ever known
and you'd be totally wrong and trump
even though he's a [ __ ] grabber
and he's full of [ __ ] and he brags about
himself became
literally the best person to make the
decisions that were the best for the
country
or would you rather the economy fall to
the toilet and trump goes to jail like
trump goes to jail
yeah yeah there's no party yeah i know
he would immediately there would be no
hesitation put him in jail [ __ ]
him everything's fine everything's fine
that sounds like a relationship whatever
makes you happy
you like [ __ ] that i don't want it to be
happy well they definitely didn't want
him to do well
which is weird like they wanted him to
get arrested and then the economy to
bounce back
that's what part of they but another
thing they wanted to joe they wanted um
to feel like uh you cared about them
they wanted to feel like
you cared about something or somebody
else other than
your fan base that was a big part of it
man people didn't
i don't think people were just looking
for reasons to hate on him and i know
some people that like
liked him some people love it
some people love to know nothing since
[ __ ] it people love a guy who came along
and said [ __ ] you the politically
correct [ __ ] too there's a lot
that people liked about him people liked
the idea that he got [ __ ] over in this
election too
they liked the idea that the deep state
was involved and that people were
rigging voting machines and miscounting
votes and
people loved those stories i do not know
if those stories are true
i don't give a [ __ ] about those stories
they're a bummer though
it's a bummer that there's those stories
this would be the ideal scenario
whoever won one if it's biden and comma
they win
and then that's it the transfer of power
shake of hands people do what they've
always done with obama do whatever you
don't want to do that son they don't
want to do that
that's so corny you don't want to shake
him up okay you don't want to give him
the secrets
you don't give up the keys he's got it
give up the cards
he's got to do it especially if he wants
to run again see if trump wants to do it
again he could run one more time in 2024
but the only way he's going to be able
to do that he's got to be able to
sit down and shake biden's hand and say
i'll see you in four years [ __ ]
he's got to be you can't said that you
can't just keep saying
that the voting is a hundred percent
rigged and i won this election by a lot
and all that's [ __ ] dangerous because
it's just dangerous for our confidence
it's dangerous yeah people talking about
rise up you're gonna it's gonna be
something something's going to do don't
say that
here's the thing i you got to show the
evidence
first you got to show the evidence first
there's just to be like you have to
compile all that evidence if there
really is that evidence
you got to compile it all and present it
in a very solid way
shut down yeah it's um
it's not i mean it's above our pay grade
dc even understand
national politics on that scale but i
think that as a country i think you and
i
both know that this country's this is
like
it's never been a position where you
don't know what the hell is going to
happen you never know like with
you never know there's there's so much
turmoil and weirdness and you never know
what is there going to be another wave
of this pandemic are they going to shut
everything down again
whatever what happens then whatever
happened then we go with
what has become our new norm we go back
to that you know i'm saying like
things are about to shift by the spring
or the summer this is going to be
in a totally different place in regard
to how people feel about
being in public again they're going to
have this
they're going to come up with some super
rapid testing situation
i hope that's going to make the [ __ ]
um essential workers people in medical
field
feel more comfortable they're going to
make other people feel comfortable
and eventually like people are going to
make decisions am i going to [ __ ]
hope so what am i going to do
to live i hope the vaccine and you know
that the election gets resolved quickly
jamie if you had a guess
if you would no i know but i mean let
them let trump say its result
if you had a guess what percentage
of uh election fraud do you think there
was
take a guess it's not zero right
probably not zero but it's like one two
percent like the normal
polled i think it's really one percent
that's a lot i mean there's 150 million
votes
i don't think it's i don't think it's a
lot i don't think it's one but i think
it's
i think there's a some less than zero
number
or some more than zero number rather
that is uh voter fraud
i think that any reasonable person point
one of points yeah
it's not and who knows which way it goes
because i bet there's voter fraud the
other way too
we're not hearing about that because
biden won but
if biden was like trump and he lost that
race who knows
he might they might try to figure out a
way that the republicans cheated
i don't know man yo i'm gonna tell you
this [ __ ]
has turned into comedy son what's turned
into comedy
this whole just not quitting just it's
kind of crazy
no it's every day it's tweeting no it's
not even crazy it's
entertaining it's entertaining
i know it's unfortunate for me
entertainment but it's entertaining
i get that it's entertaining but it
makes me nervous
it makes me nervous when you start
thinking that there's people out there
that think that
um that there's been a coup right
or that trump is attempting a coup
there's like two different schools of
thought
one school of thought is the deep state
took over the election and they they
they rigged it and the other school of
thought is this guy is trying to win
even though he lost
and he's trying to figure out a way to
sue his way back into the white house
and this is crazy so this is good
yeah so there's uh that's the problem is
that there's not enough he's gonna
win one end because he's got the power
of the people like again
those of him losing the support that he
has he knows that there's a community
he can they're gonna be [ __ ] still on
his dick right now because
he can shake some [ __ ] up yeah i said
[ __ ] him
[ __ ] all of them am i ever going to get
some help do you have any help today
i have it at my house yeah you can't
cook it though right
i can cook it we have to figure out how
much time we have between now and the
show
yo you can bring some elk to the show
son not enough for everybody
no just a sample yeah why don't you just
come over my house i'll cook for you
what time do we have i don't know we'll
figure it out when we get out of here
let's figure it out off the air though
but my two lesbian friends are supposed
to meet me son
they're not like no like no menage a
troia lesbians
she's like regular lesbians they're my
friends okay that's cool
yeah who do they think won
biden what hell
man what i said my two lesbian friends
lesbians adopted mexican son eli who i
[ __ ] love
you don't think there's lesbians for
trump i bet there's a whole website i
don't you know what i never thought
about that i don't think it's too many
lesbians for trump
i bet there's a few i bet they get
together and like yeah you know like
people
i don't know i don't think that that's
never that's what i never thought about
you know that's what's for trump some
people are really into anime
there's a t-shirt there goes lesbian for
trouble oh no
[Laughter]
it's funny but you would assume that if
someone's a lesbian that's what i was
kind of getting at
that you would instantly know who
they're voting for right
i mean i know that's kind of profound
but i was definitely like a short
haircut
you know short haircut [ __ ] man cut
out suit with the
tie right like how many girls with blue
hair or pink hair
voted for trump is it less than zero
that's a good stat yeah
trump pride gay republicans on why
they're backing the president
because they get to dress up again again
have a good time it's a cool outfit
it's uh such a weird time man such a
weird time
but i'm ready to just get on the river
bro i get it i'm ready nature into some
nature
do you think you're gonna move there
would you move there i think so
it's a good place to be i think the
community i mean it's just like
just such a community man this summer
and it was just so
simple would you um would you get rid of
your place in la and just settle down
there yeah i could do that
i could do i could do it better for
travel
really if you wanted to go left or right
you're more closer to the middle
for everything man i just want to be
around some trees
i think that's one good thing about
people that can escape from la there's a
lot of people that are escaping from new
york as well and they're moving to the
the suburbs and they're they're liking
it better they're more relaxed
or get some space people who are like
instead of being in the chaos
yeah i can drive to the chaos yeah you
know it's like [ __ ] people from
we're not even drive now a lot of people
are working from home
so you don't think it's going to change
i think there's going to be a lot of
companies that realize like hey i don't
need this gigantic
space to handle all these people i can
let people work from home they're more
productive because a lot of times
people in offices they get together they
talk they have fun
you know there's a lot of work oh man i
used to [ __ ] be in the [ __ ] break
room i never was doing work
always in the breakdown i've seen dudes
in cubicles doing this [ __ ]
whether the cubicle's here and they're
both on the outside they're just having
a conversation they're nowhere near
their computer
people do that all the time if no one's
watching
people do that all the time in some jobs
don't get it don't get personal if it's
you
back from the cubicle that's hilarious
there's a lot of dudes that are working
all over the place that would be more
productive
if they just had a certain amount of
work to do and they could just get it
done at home
you know but sometimes they want to
patrol i think it's a good idea there's
a lot of people that have jobs you have
to be there
right auto mechanic a lot of people fill
in the blank
carpenter a lot of people have jobs got
to be there but there's certain jobs
like why do you need yeah why do you
need to sit through an hour and 15
minutes of traffic
when you can just do it through zoom and
just sit here in a pair of shorts and a
t-shirt and get all your [ __ ] work
done
like what why do you why do you need to
go somewhere you don't
with computers today you don't have to
go anywhere you don't have to go
anywhere they just want to control the
movements of it they just want to
it's it makes sense and i think it's
going to go to that everybody's like i'm
working from home i'm working from home
and they're getting
getting the job done yeah everything is
different a lot of people are going to
be able to stay home
and so i think that's just going to
change the nature of cities in general
less people are going to
have to commute to them but that's one
probably good thing about this
is that people are going to not have to
commute as much so maybe the roads won't
be as jammed up
if that that saves people so much
[ __ ] stress
if you're a dude who works in orange
county and you live in l.a and you got
to make that drive every morning you
ever see that [ __ ] drive
that's right i'm not driving insane i've
come from that job i've
been going the other way of that drive
when you go orange county to l.a
at 7 00 am you want to just [ __ ] end
it
you just you just like i can't do this
every day but you can do it for a minute
because that's the route that i
because i um my account is out in orange
county
and i did that trip a couple times and i
kind of enjoyed being up in the in the
morning with it
because i don't have to do i didn't do
it because you don't have to do it every
day if you had a job
and you had to be at your job at 8 30 in
the morning every day and you live in
orange county you got to go to l.a you
got to leave your house before 7.
yeah you're going to accept the fact
that every morning there's a likelihood
a high likelihood it's going to take you
an hour and a half
or you could lose zoom where you're
going zoom i wanna zoom yeah and you can
wake up instead of waking up at six
you wake up at eight you wake up at
eight have a cup of coffee
sit down turn on your [ __ ] computer
i get a little bit of toast i got maggie
i understand yeah i gotta get up early
i'm not like
the old the old donald is gone joe i get
it
like she's down there curled up i'm just
happy
that there's alternatives for some
people where they at least can work if
they can't be in an office at least they
can do some stuff on zoom
but for other people man that's what i
was that's what i'm worried about what
i'm worried about is everything
restarting like how does man joe joe
joe i know you worried about it and you
have concerns that everybody worried
about have concerns
but adventurous like this yo what the
[ __ ] are you gonna do
you gotta figure it out people are gonna
have to figure it out yeah man it's like
i understand you keep saying yeah man
then i feel sorry for them
sorry eventually you're gonna have to
figure it the [ __ ] out
eventually nobody's gonna be able to
help you
nobody's going to be able to vouch for
you and you got to do it your [ __ ]
self
dave david gaga said it man it goes back
to that same point man they looking for
answers
you are the answer you got
two excuses a good one and a bad one at
the end of the day
it's the same [ __ ] excuse i've said
it before
and i know people like well it's easy
for you to say it's not easy for anybody
to say
whatever's going to happen moving
forward it's not easy for anybody to say
everybody's gonna have their opinion of
it everybody's gonna be on the opinion
of
well give him a chance maybe he could
bring the world back together
it's gonna be a lot of trump
[ __ ] like yo [ __ ] you [ __ ]
there's been no supporter that's been
angrier than the trump supporter
to the extent that they're sore winners
and sore losers you got to pick a sword
[Laughter]
you can't just take both swords you see
the thing is they think they got robbed
that's why his tweets are dangerous and
even if you do joe yeah
even if you do have you feel this is the
part that's [ __ ] up is this mine
i have something this is the part that's
[ __ ] up sitting here for a while
probably not hot anymore
what was i saying son this is the part
that's [ __ ] up about being sore
winners and sore losers you gotta pick a
sore
you gotta pick a sword and everything is
not gonna always go your way
but you don't have to be upset about it
see the thing is though
what he's saying to them is it was a
robbery
so he thinks it's a robbery it's
definitely starting [ __ ] that's you got
it that's it right there yo why all your
[ __ ] gotta be extra strong man this is
like sturdy coffee
what's that does he want to come in
who out there dave's out there tell that
[ __ ] to come in son
yeah tell him to come on in come on do
we have a camera for him
maybe that's when he's waiting but he
gets tested every day doesn't he
maggie just jumped up have you ever seen
a baby
dog little tiny little dog i've never
seen a tiny little dog
i had one i used to have one it wasn't
quite that small but it was pretty small
i've seen little dogs i've just never
seen one in the baby form
squad david what's up
what's happening oh no
you wanna sit right here
i don't know how many microphones we
have unfortunately
my guys is there
um is there any coffee
yeah this is coughing the japanese start
small
what's up man what are you doing oh bro
living the dream good to see you how's
austin be treating you
uh great we did two nights uh at stubbs
stubs barbecue the guy from the barbecue
sauce
so he has a like a stage it's an outdoor
you've never been there it's outdoor
event you know
joe you will love this they said you was
there
no they said you were somewhere else i
went to the vulcan gas company that's
the only place i've been in town
michelle is doing it
oh that's great that's the gig she's got
coming up yeah cause cap city's gone so
people are doing shows anywhere they can
are you gonna are you gonna buy a club
here
yes you got to yes i'll be the first gig
all right you heard it here folks
i felt like i have to it's like as soon
as cap city went under i was like oh
[ __ ]
oh now i have to but i i don't know
what's going to happen after biden gets
into office whether there's going to be
another lockdown
like a national lockdown for a while so
i'll wait until after that blows over
yeah i just keep moving forward that's
all yeah you know what i mean like
everything that i've seen you do
moving here to austin and you just gets
gangsters correct
thanks we find a way yeah we find a way
we were just talking about that
people find a way i was saying like what
are people gonna do
you know with restarting the economy and
you know trying to get a job when all
these businesses went under like how
does everything go
and don i was just saying we do what we
have to do we figure it out that's true
i'm far from an economist but i will say
that
planning for your future is a good thing
it's a necessary thing
even even though it's uncertain you have
to remember the sun does rise
every morning yeah so just keep moving
and people that are in this [ __ ] right
now
never thought that it was going to
happen now that they know that this is a
possibility now we have to plan for the
future
for the future yeah i've never seen this
before never you know
you've never seen something as large as
the american economy stop
and then start back up but it's a global
phenomenon it's like it's
it's not like it's just happening to us
we're just handling it terribly i like
how you handle it though i like doing
those shows
that you did in yellow springs it's a
great idea it was wonderful
we did it in that chapel that whole area
outside
yeah there's a brazilian all outdoors i
talked to my doctor
my family practitioner and he told me
you should play outdoors
if you play indoors use uv air filters
you know like the specs of a building
that might be safer
many buildings now today are not
outfitted this way
and and you know you hope for the best
you take every necessary precaution
reasonable precaution and and but it's a
pandemic there's no guarantees
are you getting any people giving you
[ __ ] about doing shows
no no nothing i mean even if i did you
know what i mean who cares
[Laughter]
and that's it there's nothing you can do
about it
nobody no matter what you know
read about jesus seem to be a really
good guy
they killed him that's just the nature
of people
donald this dog is hilarious man this
dog
is a angel this dog makes everybody feel
good
she's so cute i've never seen a little
dog
as a baby i've only seen them as
full-grown little dogs
this this is gonna be her size right
here that's how she's gonna stack
yeah she's gonna stay like this with a
little bit more bark and more
oh now how is it traveling with it is it
more or the company i mean it's dope
like i'm like when i got her i was like
this oh she's an emotional dog right
but now that i got him like this yeah
i'm an emotional human
oh and like like yo let me tell you
something sometimes i'll be up at 5
30 and she'll be up her ears and be up
looking like what we doing [ __ ]
and i'm like at least somebody
understands me right it increases the
amount of love you have
yeah right because you're this dog and
she follows me everywhere
yeah well i was at the show the other
night i was on stage and they said she
was shaking barking when she heard my
voice
yeah it's crazy she was she was like
where are you at
she loves you yeah it's a different
world man you got a little dog that
counts on you like that
those are different kinds of dogs too
they're so little they have to be held
you need to carry them most of the time
she's scared of cold like why is she
shaking
she might be a little combination of
both
she maybe she needs a drink maybe she
has to piss she's five months old how is
she keeping it together
don't talk about her like that she's
good she
probably just needs a little warmth do
you have do you have dogs
yeah i only have one dog you probably
have a huge wolf kind of dog no
i have a golden retriever i have the
sweetest dog in the world he's the
nicest target that dog looks perfect
he's so nice that dog looks like he has
a great life he's just a love
sponge like that dog is just all about
love
all he wants to do is like kiss you and
let you pet him and
who spends the most time with your dog
me probably yeah yeah i can see him i
spent a lot of time with him
we have a morning ritual what's the
ritual i just get up in the morning as
soon as i see him good morning sir
good morning sir he starts freaking out
oh
and he go for a while for a while yeah
he does that but he loves chasing balls
more than anything he's a great guy
i didn't thank you there you go
no he's a sweet dog you got a dog uh uh
three of them
what kind uh australian shepherd
and uh one kind of like this what they
call it a chowini i think they call it
it's half chihuahua half one of those
hot dogs that's the one baba remember
the one in my special baba
that's him that's your weenie you have
this and i have my dog
and then uh my my daughter has a little
uh
a little dog like this not a not a
chihuahua i can't remember what kind of
dog she is
my daughter has a chihuahua mix it's
like a chihuahua
with like i think he's got some whippet
or something in him so he's a chihuahua
with long legs
he's adorable you know i always wanted i
wanted my kids to train animals when
they were little
really that's one of these things i
should have followed through but the
reason i did it is because i wanted to
learn how to be
patient with other with people
and i figured if they train the dog or
something
it takes patience look this dog is
adorable but she don't know nothing yet
yeah she don't know [ __ ] she knows
snacks the real problem is when you get
dogs that need a lot of training like if
you want to
have a german shepherd or a working dog
like a belgian malinois a lot of people
get those dogs you don't realize like
you you basically got like a little
genius with teeth
that lives with you that wants to figure
figure out problems you know those like
uh
have you heard of those celebrity like
the german shepherds the guard dogs the
real ones with that no
200 commands yeah schutzen training
yeah yeah yeah yeah i've seen guys do
that
some comedians got one of those dogs
spent like 200 grand on it and it died
in like
a week those are crazy if you can have a
dog like that that's a commitment man
like those dogs need work that's what
i'm saying
german and [ __ ] those dogs are so smart
they're from a long history of working
dogs those are
task oriented dogs this dog's
a long history of something is she
adorable
come on maggie she is come here
she doesn't want to be held back bro
have you ever taken a dog hunting
no you can't do that right now not my
dog it's too dangerous
well you wouldn't want him to be in the
woods
first of all could probably scare off
the animals but second of all he has
like
the instincts that chase squirrels and
[ __ ] he chases squirrels but he's like a
he's a lover he's not he's there's no
aggression in him like with other dogs
like he's always the beta
he's always uh he's he tries to be the
alpha but they bark at him he's like
sorry sorry
the australian shepherd's like that
she's well she's like she's like the dog
you described that needs work
like you can tell she's a herder she
corrals kids she corrals me
and that interesting yeah they have it
in their dna
they've seen that they really do it's uh
and the dog is really smart i never
trained this dog
but you you would think i had i just
talked to it
and you could see her face trying to
figure out what i'm talking about it's
really cool
i think he's doing something with the
dog out there
to beat his dog they do figure out words
like it's not just commands like my dog
knows you hungry man you want to eat
like he knows wow he knows when i say
you hungry what do you want to do dude
you want to throw the ball he's like
what's up with the [ __ ] ball
go over by where the ball is you got to
go outside and he'll just start walking
towards the door
like he knows a few phrases because i i
definitely trained him
like sit and all that [ __ ] but some dogs
are just smarter than other dogs he's a
really smart dog
uh yeah man does he like austin do you
like it i love it
i love it i love it here what do you
what did he do that'd be like oh
darnell
[Music]
hey that's actually you did a great job
you actually put it back perfect
that's perfect i was dead in frame don't
worry about it man
damn that's the best recovery i've ever
seen from one of these stupid things
these aren't ideal these cameras mounted
on the wall
i like this setup a lot man thank you
like it feels homey you
actually just tricked me into doing the
podcast sorry that's good i don't know
i'm going to come and do it like for
real for real for real for real
okay yeah as a matter of fact i should
come after the inauguration
okay let's do it i'll come after the
inauguration that sounds great nobody
believe i got shot son
yo dave i don't know what's going on man
but everywhere i go
don't eat all right why i can't eat over
here you're gonna crunch on the air
where you're crunching in the microphone
you're eating
come on man he was gonna
he said that he was going to bring
enough elk for me and you
i would totally do that is it is it good
yes have you ever
tried a gentleman yeah it's good so what
do you do you make jerky you barbecue it
i just put it on a grill i usually uh i
put it on a
you know what a traeger grill is it's a
pellet grill so it just has like little
wood pellets they make with sawdust
the sawdust and these pellets pour it
into the machine so it's basically just
fire and wood so it's like keep it at a
low temperature control it
like 265 until it hits 120 degrees
internal temperature
then i pull it and then i sear the
outside one of two ways either i do it
in a cast iron frying pan
with beef tallow which is rendered beef
fat
oh wow or i do would have a grill i
could do it outside on
another kind of grill usually i like to
do it in the cast iron frying pan
you heard it here first joe rogan
doesn't just like killing animals he
likes cooking them too
then he always has a perfect he got this
perfect little chopping block he put him
on
i like it he always throw the jalapenos
on his side right
and it's just you see this perfectly
seared
meat and then the knife is like a
japanese some extra [ __ ]
did you see a little blood it did a
little jalapenos and he's showing off so
do you cook it all dave you're not not
anything like you guys danielle
can cook all i hear i couldn't believe
it
he challenged me i i thought he was
joking he's like i'm a cook for all
these people
i literally thought he was joking i said
he can't cook he's like what
he's like he was offended so he makes me
take him to a grocery store this is in
ohio
and i i was laughing the whole time
until he started shopping
he goes to the lady do you have clam
juice i said i've got
clam juice he's trying to ask for all
these [ __ ] ingredients
killed it cooked for like 20 of my
friends in ohio
and then went and did a show it was
amazing and then i made him
apologize to him he was like you did a
good job i was like no [ __ ]
you got to do it on stage you said you
was going to promise us on stage
[ __ ] that [ __ ] i'm saying it on the
podcast it was amazing no i made him sad
i was like he was like yeah donna i was
like nah [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did you say
how did you learn to cook just watching
my mother cook just watching cooking
shows but i do remember when i was
younger
my mother was a part of publishers
clearinghouse and i think they had like
one promotion where you get
a betty crocker's recipe book and it had
all these recipe cards
and it just send it to you and it's like
like meats and then you see all these
recipes
and i used to look at the recipe i was
like man we got [ __ ] to make
none of this with we had the recipe we
didn't have the ingredients
so i just started reading those recipe
because when i got older i was like i
should start just [ __ ] with this [ __ ]
i couldn't cook
and then i just started [ __ ] around
and just started having fun with
you go off recipes now or do you have it
in your head i go off of it 100 percent
yeah you know what i'm saying it's like
you know what cooking it's like a
technique the
art of cooking like a order cooking you
know how to cook you could cook whatever
it just all depends on
what spices or whatever but if you're
not a cook you're not a cook what's a
specialty
i don't really have a specialty really i
don't have a specialty i'll follow a
recipe somebody will do something i'll
get inspired by something
but i do know i make these garlic
noodles right
it's not a specialty but it's a whopper
it's like a wet ass [ __ ] just
it's a wet ass [ __ ] dish son
there's no way around it they love the
garlic noodles and i make a dope ass
garlic you can put whatever protein you
want on it
but the garlic noodles are [ __ ] crazy
in fact you made those at night
i did yeah you did that was i was
impressed
i yeah i probably i love this thing you
said the metaphor we had the recipes
just not the ingredients that's a good
metaphor for like a lot of things in
life we had the recipes
but none of the ingredients we didn't
have it
that's a oh that's a bar you should
write that down
yeah oh will i remember it but this is
the truth
someone will tell you it's true just
watch the podcast tomorrow
yeah everyone wants equal access to the
ingredients
that's right i had the recipe real
equality
right what's the ingredient the
difference that really is the difference
that's a great way to that's a great
metaphor
it is yeah for life
that's what i was telling y'all [ __ ]
man
it's right there yo he been not
listening to my story the whole show
i listened he doesn't believe you
anytime i mentioned i got shot
i believed him the first time i believed
him the second time
i believed him every time you know
pierre edwards
yes great comedian i i saw a video today
with some some guy's instagram he's a
comedian it was me
introducing him at a comedy club when i
was like 17. wow
someone just sent it to me at the blues
yeah from dc
which one oh yeah p.m from dc yeah you
should do the funniest joke about
getting shot
i'm not gonna do another guy's joke but
you know he got shot
in dc like one night he oh yeah i
remember that yeah
he's funny he's funny dude i got shot
nobody [ __ ] believe me man
we believe you yo are you gonna bring
some elf i told you i'll cook some
i'm ready i'm ready man
i want to see what's what they say in
the streets what's all this fuss is
about
i want some elk son yo everywhere i go
[ __ ] say did you try the elk
that's all i know what is that
is it gamey no it's not gamey it's not
like there's a
weird taste that people associate with
like venison a gamey taste
and for the most part it's either hasn't
been prepared
correctly or it wasn't taken care of
correctly after the animal died
like that's for the most part with the
game it's a different flavor
but i think what people associate with
with not tasting good like mmm
i think a lot of that a lot of it not
all of it but a lot of it isn't just
personal taste
it's bad preparation you get a steak
from a grocery store
you're assuming that professional
butchers like people to grow the cows
professional butchers all down the line
they get the
steak if you've got a guy's dear me who
knows how this guy took care of that
[ __ ] deer
you know he could have had that [ __ ]
[ __ ] nowhere no marvelous ain't no
marblization in there nowhere
sometimes people uh you know sometimes
people shoot them and
this is a good elk day right here so it
is a good outcome look wait let's what
does the captain say watch he mention
something about a jalapeno somewhere
this is the final product oh [ __ ] that's
pretty right
but what's that a dry rub what rub is
that that's a saskatchewan
blackened saskatchewan it's a traeger
rub it's like uh
like a cajun style almost but it's got
it's always like a blackened but not
like it's like a lot of salt too
delicious it's the perfect rub i love
that rub for for elk
so wait when you cook it you like you
cut it up yourself
you know how to cut steaks out of this
yes that's the whole part
that part is easy because that part is
uh what's called the back strap that's
the big
thick piece of meat that's on each side
of the spine look at the knife though
[ __ ] what kind of is that a japanese no
that's an american knife who made that
knife
what is it does it say in the caption it
doesn't there's no tag or nothing
the dude who uh made it was [ __ ] dave
you wouldn't
even watch you wouldn't eat that it's in
there somewhere same knife real close to
it so if you're killing elk
how long are you eating that elk you can
eat it for a whole year
literally a year yeah they're huge yeah
same knife here i got it there it is
the guy gave me the knife there's it
let's see neanderthal oh chumny knives
c-h-u-m and flies
knife looks dope it's a dope knife um
yeah you'd eat it for all year it's
hundreds of pounds of meat it's like 400
huge huge so okay say you're shooting
elk you
you're bow hunting i'm a mansion yeah it
what happened it runs off you got to
follow it for like
a day or two or like a year ago if you
hit them right they die pretty quick
ow okay he do it with a botox
yeah but you have to practice a lot man
this [ __ ] do with a bow
it's not easy but the point is i know
exactly where that meat's coming from
like that i know the whole chain of
command i know
everything that's happened from the time
that animal got hit until the time i'm
cooking it
that's interesting you know because yeah
it's mind-blowing
i get all my meats from strangers yeah
most people do
yeah you don't think about it i was in
alaska once and the lady told me that
she hadn't eaten something she hadn't
killed herself
uh in years wow this woman looked like
a betty crocker model like a house mom
she was working in an ammunition store
and you know i had never been to a gun
store before
it was ridiculous this is in fairbanks
alaska there was so many
like think of a kind of gun the guy goes
this is a sniper rifle it can
you can shoot a bear with this from two
miles away
couldn't imagine why i would shoot a
bear that was two miles
i couldn't i was the weirdest sales
[ __ ] and he literally said that to me
yeah that's like a thousand yards right
isn't that is it
two miles two miles way way right how
many thousand miles is a um
a mile or thousand oh five thousand feet
is a mile right it's not yards it's
close
yeah it's great so they can shoot things
they can shoot things at a thousand
yards
like snipers have hit shots at a
thousand yards
so just think of that number it was a
crazy thing to just be able to sell to
somebody you know i'm not gonna get
all that gun stuff but a mile is 5 000
and then a thousand yards a bullet
that's
crazy that's so far
that's really far that's a long that's a
long squint
yeah they could 10 000 feet for them
nothing that's not a scope though that
has to be a scope
well again this was alaska so you got to
think things like guns there
are are more utilitarian than likes you
know new york or something people do
need
you want to tuli out there i think yeah
everybody
has guns up there well they also have
bears and [ __ ] moose and [ __ ]
yeah it's crazy up there it looks it
looks unfinished it's beautiful
it's a wild place it's one of the last
real
the the people that live up there are a
different kind of human they're more
they have they just they're they're more
durable
they're not soybean eaters no they have
all these little alaskanisms
they call they call leaving alaska going
outside
really yeah they say it's like a call
they say the lower 48th we all heard
that before right yeah
they'll call the rest of the continental
us lower 48.
um tons of them but it was it was fun up
there man
nice people i've only done shows up
there once i did shows in anchorage with
ari
we had a good [ __ ] time they were
good people but they're sturdy
they're like you could tell they can
they survive winter you deal with [ __ ]
that people don't have to deal with the
male to female ratio the
male to female ratio guys out number
women in alaska i think ten to one
ten to one it's not many women
awesome [ __ ] are sexy as [ __ ]
out there [ __ ]
ten to one well yeah that's what you
would think you think oh if you're a
woman i was great
ten guys you got ten dusty dirt on the
fingernail choices these guys are rugged
right
right these guys are rugged you know
what i mean
yeah like just think of the jobs you
have i was the only dude in the nail
shop
in fairbanks alaska everybody else's
nails their hands look like [ __ ]
yo you was killing it i've been mining
all day
i met a guy as a gold miner
weird jobs like that that's how i was
when i was in the air force when i was
stationed in kunsan korea
it was like 10 guys to every girl
and whoever she was she was america's
next top
model she had the attitude
like she was like every one of them
chicks was like [ __ ]
you got to compete that's why [ __ ] was
going downtown
it's definitely an unhealthy you know
danielle you know danielle speaks
korean like thomas not fluently but just
casual
but no i didn't know that we were in new
york when we were shooting chapel show
we walk into a deli yeah
and you know two korean guys sitting
talking to each other
danielle turns up you know how he talks
he starts coming back but you know
starts
doing the thing and i thought he was
[ __ ] with him i'm like oh come on man
i'll do that like
i'm so sorry sir and the guy cause the
guy looked shocked
and then the guy started talking back
and they talked to each other for a
couple seconds
and i'm like i was floored staring at
him i couldn't believe it he goes
oh they thought he said they thought we
were stealing son and i told him
that we wasn't still i think he called
like a dog-eating [ __ ] in his
own language yeah
and he was he loved it but he said it
you promised me you call him a doggy
[ __ ] yeah kasich
yeah i he was saying something about you
while you were standing there and
he didn't know that you could speak
korean yeah it was but we were wearing
kids conversation
me and the guy was engaged in
conversation dave thought i was mocking
him
you know dave thought i was manga but i
was really having a conversation with
him so
dave didn't know he thought i was like
[ __ ] like yo you can't talk like that
and then i was rocking with him i was
like oh [ __ ] those guys were
floored i was flawed they're like when
they see a black guy going to one of
those stores
that speak any level of korean they
[ __ ] lose it like how often does that
happen
well clearly this means one could
surmise that when you were in the air
force you spent a lot of time off base
i did you would just be in town and just
hanging out i would just go when we had
days off
i would go to like these little small
cities wherever they live
just they never experienced americans
let alone a black guy
and i would catch boats and [ __ ] over
there just hang out with them
and that's how i got they got accustomed
to me and i got accustomed to them can
you read it
no i couldn't read it but i could back
in the day i could spell my name
but it was just like i was with
trustworthy people you know we all
worked together and it was just like
[ __ ] can i do man let's go see what your
culture is about
you know that's cool that you learn that
that's a rare
thing that's probably a difficult
language to pick up too the sounds are
so different
well to me i think it's a testament that
you're a people person
which goes back to the original point we
all made you find a way if you want to
hang out and talk to people and nobody
speaks your language i don't speak that
language
yeah you find a way yeah you will did
you learn from
books did you take classes at the main
gate we worked at maine gate
you would have 12 hours 16 hour days so
you it's a one american on one side and
there's two koreans on the other side
you could just stare at each other all
day or you could just start doing word
association you know i mean it's
pointing that stuff
down come someday chummy
that was the greeting i would say when
it comes some that's what they would say
come something don't trouble them but i
would switch it to me come something
i'll tell them
roland zimmer don't touch them
don't answer phone because i sound like
them and then
they would say something else i didn't
know i was like yeah yeah it comes i'm
not telling them
touch them up they'd be like oh because
your accent was perfect yeah i would do
the same like when i started learning
spanish i went to ecuador once for like
six weeks
i just started picking up spanish i had
a driver that i i just met the guy i
hired him so he would try the car
he spoke like a little bit of english
and i spoke less spanish but
we did the same thing by the end of it
by the end of six weeks
my man i could speak spanish yeah but i
wouldn't mimic
i would mimic the action of whoever
taught me the word if i learned a word
from an argentinian i'd say like an
argentinian says it if i
that's why when i when i do korean or
whatever when i do it even when i do it
in my act when it's broken korean
people know that's the oddishie he got
the tone of an older person a respected
person it's oddish
oh yeah it's like they know like
a real karen could tell who i was around
to give my my
my accent or however i did it so i have
a friend
named japanese naki i know japanese naki
yeah she she is from tokyo
and and for some reason when she was in
high school moved to alabama she
learned english from alabama people
whoa and and which created
one of the more hilarious accents i've
ever heard in my
gotta life i just like where's she got a
country
she got a country accent wow she's yeah
she's
and she likes lemon pepper chicken wings
it's that kind of stuff
yeah in other languages there's all
these weird tones that change the
meaning of words
in korean in particular right in korea
in particular because you can tell
the way people use their voice when you
talk to people older people always talk
down to people no matter what you did
it don't matter what it is for you to
celebrate it it's always like
it wasn't enough do you know that those
problems in communication is why korean
air
only teaches pilots in english they only
learn and communicate in english they're
not allowed to communicate
how do you know that well because they
started they they recognized there was
an issue
with the superior and dealing with a
superior like if you were my captain and
i was your
i couldn't say certain things to you if
the [ __ ] plane is going to crash
i can't simply say you you're doing it
the wrong way
this is you can't say it but in english
you can't so they taught them
to communicate in english because it's
it changes the way or they
only use english because it changes the
way you communicate with people you
don't have like
that cultural classification of the
superior
of you know an older person who demands
respect i get it
and that's the one thing people don't
understand about especially korean
culture
is the level of respect that they have
yeah that's that
people think it's like oh they don't
[ __ ] with me because i'm black no the
level of respect
they have they give a [ __ ] about being
older like that's
money that's prestige that's everything
you being older korean culture
was money you know i was around koreans
i like this
yeah i like this cultural nuance korea
is a
what they don't have is like like korean
dads don't really have connection with
their kids like that
they don't have like the ultimate
emotional oh you did a good job
[ __ ] don't they're very hard they're
very hard on their kids
that's it in general um i had a good
friend of mine who was a doctor
he was going through his residency
while he was on the national taekwondo
team
and the dude would literally be in
school and he would take
breaks to put his backpack on he's fill
the backpack up with with books
and run up staircases and go all the way
back down and then go back to
go into the library to finish his work
oh wow and then he would find a way to
go to the gym every day and he won the
national championship and there's this
korean kid i've never met a person who
worked harder in my life
to this day i think about that dude he
was always tired i go how are you doing
man he goes
i'm always tired i'm always that
[ __ ] every day would be in that
gym
every day junk sick chang that was his
name
is he still alive i don't know i haven't
talked to him in a long time he was
um he's just a guy that
uh was like he was probably like the
star
student of our team during my uh when i
was competing
because he was this guy that was not
just a national champion but also a guy
who did it while he was in his [ __ ]
medical residency like the amount of
work that he was capable of doing
was insane and he was like the way
koreans are
in you know the way he would describe it
to me he's like nothing's ever enough
no matter what i do it's never perfect
like
no one no one's here to praise me i
gotta keep working hard sounds like a
fun guy jesus
christ they're younger
korean military yeah it's like when you
were like
when somebody was uh outranked or
whatever they used to do this thing
called education where they could just
talk to a little korean [ __ ] any
kind of where they went
yeah and they used to have this little
greeting they used to do
and then you just see the other the
young koreans just like
like they could do whatever they wanted
to this [ __ ] he could not do
nothing but just show them
yeah you have to take it they used to
like there was no rules like
if you do this they would [ __ ] beat
the [ __ ] up or whatever they
came back
but there's one thing i like that you
described the reverence for older people
yeah i feel like here in america
we just discard people yeah really quick
yeah
it's not wise we should get more than
half price at the movies
that's a certain point yeah come on
that's the least they could do
well we've we've forgotten that it's
important to have people that are older
than you that figure
life out a little bit better than you
have to help lead the way we got guys
we're running for president the way they
kept going in on joe biden for being
old yeah you know trump you know
whatever it's whatever
so come on man like it's a trumpet
that's what i mean
i like when trump calls the elderly the
elderly as if that somehow doesn't apply
to him
yo that's how i help y'all dave i did a
show once right and i was so caught up
in myself i was like
look at all these old head [ __ ]
that i went to high school with
right i was like old ass [ __ ]
that i'm their same age i forgot that
that's real that's real every once in
they are a lot older than me and they're
the same age
yeah they're the exact same age i'm
talking [ __ ]
yeah all my all my friends around my age
you don't feel it
yeah they're more like they they have
like you know i mean they dress the part
that's why it's very important for older
people to actually have their [ __ ]
together
because when older people actually have
their [ __ ] together maybe people will
resume
the idea of respecting older people like
maybe
maybe it'll become more of a trend in
the future but whenever
all the people are that old and they're
still crazy
when that's a problem with a guy like
trump that old and still i won this and
big
like all the craziness like the girl
used to bang called her horse face on
twitter like that kind of crazy
yeah that kind of craziness it's like
but you come to expected of him though
it became very entertaining man he made
it all entertaining but then it was a
show
in people's lives but it's like close
like you know how
you'll see old person dressed up and you
know that
maybe like 30 years ago that outfit was
the
[ __ ] you know what i mean yeah
but but but maybe he's not killing it
today and it's it's like you
you could see him put it on one time and
just be like this is it go on without me
fashion keep going isn't it funny how
fashion eventually comes back around
and then you got dudes dressing up like
they're old-timey photographers
when i grew up this summer for me i just
grew up with it
i don't even give a [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying i'm like i remember this
summer sun i was starting to buy [ __ ]
that had waterproof on it you know what
i mean reversible
i was i was like [ __ ] that [ __ ] city
boy [ __ ]
i was buying [ __ ] that was fitting for
the condition and the weather that i was
in
right clothes become utilitarian yeah i
was like
brother you get out of a city your guy
wears a work clothes
for you know to work in the world that's
right everything's practical
alaskans understand that [ __ ] boy do
they they get it
it'd be a hard place to go like if i had
to go buy some clothes for a date in
alaska
boy that's a tough one yeah yeah you
have nothing to do i hope you like
waders [ __ ]
you got a few days a year where it's
cold where it's not cold outside
and those days it's light 24 hours but
those people are conditioning for it now
but that's where it's weird when it's 24
hours out of it they had all these signs
up because this was like in november
all these it was like game of thrones
winter is coming and
there were these signs that said get
your happy lights have you heard of this
no
they're like uh uv lights that people
put in their house to
to mimic sunshine just so that they
don't get depressed
i couldn't sleep they're homegrown man
it's like all
that's crazy do you remember that uh
there was a vampire movie
a few years back called 30 days of night
i don't know it's all about vampires
that show up in alaska because there's
30 days
where it never gets light out oh that's
a good premise so these vampires just
[ __ ] this town up for 30 days
because they know when so they they
bring this vampire familiar that pulls
the boat into
the anchorage shore or whatever the [ __ ]
they landed and they get out in this
small
town and just wreak havoc on this town
for 30 days
robin williams and al pacino did a movie
the opposite of that it's called
insomnia you ever seen that
i didn't see that it was a weird
character thing pacino's character
uh is a cop uh this is real
and and and rob uh robin williams is
a guy he's looking for for an anus crime
right
the the backdrop of the movie was that
it was daylight
for 24 hours a day and the guy had
terrible insomnia
oh
that's a rough way to live when it never
gets dark out
i remember doing it uh when i was in
anchorage i was with uh did shows up
there with aries fear and we went uh
fishing and it was like two o'clock in
the morning it was bright outside i was
like this is weird man
i would love that it's weird
it i would love it too fishing at two
o'clock oh yeah you can just keep going
there's parts where it gets dark
like bears did you fly you fly fish no
we uh we're trolling for salmon
how do you travel for salmon you pull a
boat you've got like a boat and you
cast some lures in and you're really
trying to get the salmon aggravated
that's what they wanted they're not
really hungry at that point they're
trying to [ __ ]
so when they they get your lure they're
really pissed off at it more than
anything
jesus christ people have thought of
everything who the [ __ ] would think to
aggravate a fish aggravate salmon yeah
somebody that needed that
yeah there's certain salmon that only
eat plankton they don't need they eat
like microscopic [ __ ]
like they don't really eat fish this is
in a river you're doing it yeah you
you pull lures but i think that's um
is that chinook or sockeye or i'm trying
to figure out which one doesn't really
eat
fish and the only time you catch them is
when you piss them off i don't know
nothing about my salmons
like sockeye i don't know my salmons had
different personalities than anything so
well some some fish just eat fish right
and some fish just eat microscopic [ __ ]
and there's one
particular type of salmon that only eats
microscopic [ __ ] and the way you catch
it
is by getting it pissed and that's in
alaska they do that out of like bristol
bay
i think that's chinook is that correct
and uh salmon migrate right yeah they
migrate
yeah so are they salt water or are they
fresh water houses
they're both okay that's what i thought
yeah they're they they move
through i forget what it's called but
they uh they go out to salt water
and they come back to spawn in fresh
water and they have to do it in the same
river
so if you damn the river up they're
[ __ ] and they die
they don't know where to go and they
they never wind up reaping which is one
of those figures that's
money like which one is it salmon's huge
well you know out of all fish
it's like probably tuna really yeah but
there's you know they're running out of
tuna man
they keep just jacking tuna talk to
those old tuna guys
in japan and they're like we used to see
a lot of tuna
now you go to the tuna market it's a
fraction of what it used to be there's
just not as much tuna left
yeah people love sushi i know they do in
atlanta
this was a lot of money
what happened he's referring to it
i know that love of sushi and atlanta
bro they had a big thing about sushi in
atlanta
what happened quick question quick
question before i go this is what
because this is coming up and the next
time we meet i want to ask you about
what you think the vaccine are you
taking it
i'll take it if it works if i feel that
the doctors have all
gotten their opinions behind it and they
think you know what it is is like an
mrna
vaccine this new vaccine that makes your
body think that
it doesn't introduce actual covenant
your system and you fight it off it
makes your body think that it's covered
and your body builds the proper proteins
to fight it off
a guy explained it to us yesterday
nicholas christakis he's from yale
um he thinks he likes no he doesn't he's
a good man
he uh he thinks that he's a great man
and
i won't let you disparage him like no
i'm not disparaging he's like he's
certain [ __ ] a soy bean muffin
soybean he's a doctor okay anyway
he uh he thinks the vaccine will be uh
very effective
and uh even if you if it doesn't keep
you from getting it it'll prevent
or hopefully prevent you from getting a
bad case of it
i don't know though so so what would you
need would you would you
would you need just the consensus of a
body of doctors you trust
and people's experiences because people
have already taken it so if people have
taken it like what is the experience
they say that they
you know had uh they felt like [ __ ] for
a few days that's it
now is that true i mean who are they
have you talked to them what's a few
days and what do you mean by feel like
[ __ ] like did you
try running four days later and you
still felt terrible like so it
apparently they're distributing this
vaccine
almost now right i don't think it's
totally ready but it very soon
will be ready and uh if it's effective
they're going to encourage people to
take it
it's it makes people feel really nervous
for like doctors and like essential
people
yeah first and then um it's going to
probably people that are high risk like
yeah but the thing is it's going to have
people have a sense of like there is
something that could be done now
like it's a sense of hope it's a sense
of progress it's a sense of like
you know we it was at one time we didn't
have a thought of a
vaccine now we got competitors and [ __ ]
yeah people to think different
listen if it works we should take it
just but
i know how people get real nervous
people don't [ __ ] with vaccines i told
you that son
how do you feel about it hey black
people don't [ __ ] with no vaccines dave
well i mean i feel like it's
inconclusive
because your caveat was i'd take it if i
felt
safe about it yeah well that's just just
the thing don't you feel like that same
way
of course but so now
you know for the first time we're
learning we're learning how a drug
the process of a drug you know going
through trials we're learning this
literally as a nation we're all watching
this thing take place an accelerated
version of it an accelerated version of
it because usually a vaccine takes
multiple years to develop
yeah so this is uh really quick to be
able to have something this quick and
turn it around and it's like those
movies where they find a cure by the end
and you're like oh it's [ __ ]
they're doing it well not a cure but a
vaccine that's a big deal
it's the good thing is if another one
comes around
they're going to be more prepared to do
something like this quicker
right like i think people needed to
really
understand that in our lifetime
something can kill the world's economy
and and kill hundreds of thousands of
people here and a million people
worldwide
i think everybody i don't think we i
think we knew it but i don't think we
really
expected it right now they knew it they
were the obama administration had
prepared for precisely that eventually
reality
but i mean us of course we couldn't
write my mind around it
even if they told you even if you
watched bill gates speech and ted talk
in 2015
you would never internalize it and think
there's there's a pandemic coming
now nobody now we know there is now the
the we're going to
want to invest in the the medical
infrastructure to make sure that they
prepare better next time this is
hopefully people are going to learn from
this that's
oh yeah 100 people know glass has
nothing to go
nothing is going to be new there's
nothing going to be new about it no
well the debate is is largely
philosophical right
i mean to this thing there's two schools
of thought
one school of thought is it's just going
to be what it's going to be
and we'll you got to keep moving like
why close anything
and the other school thought which i
thought was you know it was more than
just a philosophy
it was it was a science right remember
the premise when they locked us up was
we have to wait to catch up to our
medical infrastructure yeah so we don't
over burden our medical infrastructure
we got to suppress the disease
till we can build up the infrastructure
and they gave us an early estimate of
two weeks this is how a comedian does
when the comedian is doing a real long
set he goes one more thing before i go
and then he does that four or five times
and you realize oh this guy's going to
do another hour oh yeah that's so
[ __ ] rude yeah yeah but you know that
trick yeah
that's what the pandemic the corn team
felt like
two more weeks three more weeks maybe
we'll open bars and
you know that kind of [ __ ] but there's
no way to control it other than create
it yourself right
what do you mean like the the whole vibe
of
the the scene right the vibe of which
scene
the pandemic you said how do we get used
to it what can we do about it well he's
also saying
here's the thing we never signed up to
let people tell us that we can and can't
take risks or go to work
and by saying that if you do it you're
going to kill other people that's what
changed the game
right and so everybody has to figure out
how much of that they're willing to
accept
and how much of that are they not and
whether or not they're willing to take a
shot
um take this this vaccine without
you know knowing the long-term effects
of it or worrying about the long-term
effects of and some people are
naturally averse to taking any kind of
medication they don't want to do it and
other people are like if you tell me
it's good
and all the doctors agree and it'll help
mankind
i'll [ __ ] do it that's how i feel if
i
listen polio okay [ __ ] doesn't exist
anymore smallpox doesn't exist anymore
at least not in the numbers that it used
to be right
because that's because of vaccines like
the idea that vaccines have done bad
things
only or that they're dangerous only it's
crazy like vaccines are the responsible
for the
giant vaccine i think the at the core
this is you just trust
yes do you trust these sources and
people realize that they're at the mercy
of someone that they don't necessarily
trust right that's the that's interrupt
well maybe maybe don't don't problem
touch your own face
don't go outside i'll tell you when to
come out said love a renowned liar
yeah right tough one that was a tough
one
especially here it goes something really
touches something really sore in the
core of an american's identity
like you said how can you tell me to do
this yeah
it's crazy man this was a tough one here
it's a weird one
it makes us redefine what it is to be a
person
you know like if all of a sudden you
have other people that got elected
into a position of power that's all they
did they want a popularity contest and
they're dictating
whether things go this way or that way
and they don't necessarily have the
right answer
they just have their own answer and
dallas is doing it different that this
town
and you know washington state's doing it
different than nevada everyone's doing
it different
but everybody's trying to do it also
yeah but governors can tell you what you
can and can't do
it gets real weird and i get it they're
trying to keep the hospital numbers down
but you told us it was going to be two
weeks
like you guys said two weeks and now
here we are like nine months later and
everyone's just waiting for
only for a vaccine but i'm not speaking
about you know
if it's right if it's wrong i'm not
speaking about like that i'm just saying
whatever it was
that was very difficult yeah that was
very difficult very difficult you know i
was fine
but not knowing when you can work not
being able to move around not being able
to see my mother
you know you would never thought if
someone had told me
11 months ago even the night before they
the last night we went to
milwaukee yes it was perhaps the last
show
it was the last night between shows
right it's a two show night
uh and the energy had changed it went
from festive to like
people look worried when i got off stage
and
tom hanks had had it the one nba guy who
would touch everything that had it
and then the horn starts ringing they're
going to shut the country down
i i literally go that's impossible
we're going to shut down the world it's
impossible this is this is what i
thought my initial reaction
but the energy changed now i go out and
do the second show and immediately and i
wasn't even thinking about this [ __ ]
earlier tonight
i come out on stage and everybody reach
your hand hey
i thought about it okay
i start you know shaking people's hands
oh i'm
worried but yeah it was just but yeah
the neighbor for
wouldn't have even been concerned about
it went into the green room for 40
minutes and talked to people who've been
glued to the television watching the
news and then they
they scared the [ __ ] out of me my
behavior changed almost instantly it's
interesting
i don't get too heavy i mean i'm only
hanging out with him no man that's how
it's this thing
it's not too heavy that's exactly how i
felt about it too i remember i
shook a dude's hand on a flight i was
flying to vegas for the fights it was
like one of the last fights before they
shut it down and uh some dude goes i
don't know you want to shake hands like
i'll shake your hand
we shook him he had a mask on already
and i was like wow
he was ready to go down he was i think
this was the very beginning of march
this was the first the first time i
would have been um
tested any capacity was when i did your
show that time
that was the first time i had an
antibody test or anything
i would have never expected that here we
would be deep into november
and we're all still kind of locked down
when this started you lived in l.a you
had no plans to come here yeah you're in
texas think about it your whole
your whole life has changed what's
interesting about this time was another
thing we should talk about next time
would come
is that the in mass it feels like we're
rewriting our social contracts you know
the whole thing
and covet is an accelerant on this
process
that i could have never imagined yeah
you know they'll they're locked inside
man people are
are stuck in a house with their choices
do you like your house
do you like who you're with do you like
these things you've accumulated i hope
you like them because you're stuck with
them
i make great choices i like my choices
you know when i was faced with it like
that i was like
i had it much better than many people
but imagining people doing that in
mass is pretty powerful it's a pretty
powerful
thought what does this do to a society
this type of isolation and
and almost forced reflection yeah which
is not
necessarily a bad thing right and
we've always talked about how life is a
rat race right people get
stuck in this rat race it feels never
ending
it's not good that all these people lost
their jobs it's not good that all these
people are going to lose where they live
it might help some people recognize
that if you just keep going in this rat
race it just it never ends you got to
figure out a way out
and now is the better time to figure out
a way out than ever
because you kind of have to you kind of
have to and society as it existed 10
months ago it's not the same place it's
the same
what's the country what's the country
that there's a country
maybe somewhere in south pacific or
something that measures their
their success as a nation with what they
call their gross national happiness this
totally different premise what country
is that i can't remember
maybe maybe you google gross national
happiness
thanks fingers
[Laughter]
says bhutan there it is bhutan there you
go this is a real this is a real
principle it's a philosophy guys the
government
think about this this is a philosophy
that guides the government of bhutan it
includes an
index which is used to measure the
collective happiness this is the metric
that they use
to define their success if they tried
that in america they'd turn into an app
and it would [ __ ] up everything
oh my god people would just be striving
to win the points on the app
it would make people insane they'd get
addicted to trying to be a better person
this is this is the vastly this is a
vastly better
metric i'm not you know a communist none
of that [ __ ]
but i i think that i know too many
people who are very wealthy
who have what i consider poor quality of
life just because
like you say the wealth is the point
yeah
they chased it they chased it and they
didn't have any friends
right you're very welcome you're hunting
you love your dog
your dog hangs out with you like [ __ ]
scooby doo your kids like
your kids like you you you you're living
an adventure of a life now you're doing
the same thing you're doing in l.a in a
totally different city just because
you're following that knowing feeling i
got to be free
whatever it is there's a little bit of
that and then there's also like uh
i think you're better off living in a
place with less people i think
when you live to be you live in a place
with like l.a
it's great in that there's a lot of
resources there's a lot of [ __ ]
happening there's a lot of people
but it's bad in that sometimes people
it diminishes the value of people a
little bit when there's so many of them
like people stop thinking about nlp is
valuable i don't even think that it's
it's that for me the thing the thing
that i
always had a hard time with was the
point of the place was show business
yeah so when i was coming up in my
career everything reminded me
of the things i didn't have and nothing
let me appreciate where i was and then
now i love it it's a winner's circle i'm
doing great so i can get in any
restaurant
you know yeah but i remember what it
felt like being there
it's like that's why i don't live there
no disrespect to l.a but it's like if i
like a restaurant i don't move in and
say
i just come when i want to eat almost
live in the restaurant
i think your your idea of living in
another place gives you perspective
there's no question it's the best way to
have perspective if you're stuck in that
showbiz world you know that becomes your
culture
your culture is like this tiny fraction
of the human beings in the world and so
many people just start relating only to
people in that culture
like that you can get real isolated that
way
yes it's not yeah and and and for what
we do for a living
how is that conducive to anything yeah
we want to see
why artistically no it's a very wise
decision like really what
yes that smells great i told you son
that's the ones
that candle is the [ __ ] i'll do a
commercial for right now you cut this
out a thing
hi i'm dave chappelle and this is a
black ash candle smells way better than
it sounds
take it from me and ask you larry black
ass
[ __ ] cut
one take yay that's beautiful give it to
me i'll light it
oh yeah do that get the scent going
so uh when you touring now do you just
pick a city and say oh i'm gonna do
denver
three nights in a row find me a venue
well i don't know if i want this on a
show but
just between us well you could i don't
know i'm not trying to we don't have to
put anything on the show that you
but i want to post up here for like you
know
a few weeks it's cold in ohio i like
playing outdoors
i like this stubs place a lot beautiful
it's rocking
so i cut that's what i said we do damn
thing i'm thinking around
december january uh stay here for four
to six weeks trying to finish the act
that i was
boy i was close when we when we were
supposed to do those shows and
man that summer was gonna be fire
me and joe rogan went on sale with some
tickets this is
this joe we must have sold 36 000
tickets
in like 10 minutes it was it was insane
we were so excited to do the show
and like a week or two before yeah the
shutdown happened
i was part of that [ __ ] and it was about
to be nice so the ones we did were fun
too though
what was it yeah yeah no i've never seen
you have bet remember we
watched once upon a time in hollywood
and all that yes it was so much fun two
o'clock in the morning
the conversation was there we were yeah
you were there
yeah you were there that was when we
were in uh no that was no it was seattle
that was yeah it was tacoma seattle
that's right that was fun that was fun
so much fun the conversations we have in
the green room
you know every every tour has its own
culture but the culture of this tour
that we did together
was great yeah inf was who was traveling
with you but he was always famine man he
was always tired from not getting the
right proteins yeah
yo this [ __ ] slept the whole joint son
but
ian and i the first time i'd ever left
the country i was like
18 i had my 19th birthday there in
scotland i did the edinburgh festival
and ian edwards was on the festival
doing a show
you know black dudes from from the west
like way west man we hit it off we would
crack each other up
and uh and then bam i just see him you
know on the road
made me feel 20 years younger and we you
know we all sit around the green
room the lights are red music's good
really good vibes really good company it
was it was a perfect match
you you nail it with the red lights in
your room it changes everything
i'm gonna steal that from you oh man man
please be my guest maybe i'll go with
purple
it's all about the umbrella because i
used to just sit in a room with hard
white lights
and a fruit plate that i don't know how
long it has been there
and no music and you know the early days
no friends you're just sitting in there
with a maybe maybe a joke book just
waiting just waiting all the time just
waiting just waiting
and at some point you realize well this
has got to be fun
i can't just be sitting in these rooms
looking at these walls
who the [ __ ] has to bring a book to work
right it was that
it was that so i just started sexing it
up like just having fun
and and and then when you start getting
bigger on the road
you start bringing your friends out and
all that [ __ ] then it gets really fun
and you become like a surrogate family
the longer you stay out together you
know you learn each other's creature
habits you find out [ __ ] about each
other you don't know you see
[ __ ] about the shacks i see what what
people are made of man we had some of
the ropes
man yeah so much [ __ ] fun
yeah you would love that ohio [ __ ] yeah
you remember that i wish i could have
gone but that's when i was planning on
coming maybe that night that we
not doing any stand up i had my drone
that night
oh yeah yeah yeah we had my drone i
don't even know how to fly my own drone
one of my friends was flying the drone
and it was late at night was like yo
get the drone shot so we get the drone
shots and then the drone went up in the
air it's like about two o'clock in the
morning and we thought we lost the drone
we didn't see no red lights no blue
lights it was just god we was like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] we got to go find a drone we
like
we about to get out of here we thought
we lost the drone the drone was supposed
to be at
um at the um bed and breakfast
well can you control those things like
the people that know how to drive it
they can control where they can't see it
through like measurements and distance
and everything
yes things are good though they had
buttons on the you know they could track
track a person on an object if you
wanted to just follow a car or anything
like that
really remember in l.a the paparazzi
started doing all this crazy drone [ __ ]
i'm sure they got you
the drone guys we had the drone shot i
was drinking coffee
you hear the buzzing yeah you hear this
[ __ ]
and you know that there's a dude a block
away somewhere isn't that weird like
they could
they could kind of find you now with a
drone well we did the drone shot from
the place
we thought we lost we was going to go
and search i was like get my
[ __ ] drone [ __ ]
right we get ready get everybody in the
car to go find this drone
we don't see this guy nowhere to all of
a sudden suddenly it was like a movie
we saw these blue lights come up and we
heard this
and that [ __ ] came everybody was
like oh [ __ ] they got the drone
and that [ __ ] came all the way back down
son oh that was a good shot
that was a great shot i met the governor
of texas
i went to the mansion to hang out with
him governor abbott and i had
whiskey and barbecue with him and while
we're hanging out at his house a drone
comes by
and hovers in the sky that's the one the
light goes on
and we're watching this drone the
security guys are trying to figure out
where the drone's coming from and who's
got the drone
and it turned out to be like the fire
department the fire department has their
own drone
and they're flying their drone around
looking for stuff that makes a lot of
sense man
but they they're like that's like how
you can spot fires how they can figure
out what's going on
if there's some sort of car accident
they could probably send a drone out
get video image of it so they know what
to expect when they get there
makes sense right there's a new car like
that
some it's a drone the headlights are
drones
you gotta look this up man what is it
the headlights fly away
what do you mean the headlights are
attached to the car
right they're on if you get out of the
car
they pop off and start flying around and
make a
path of light that's that's i think
that's the thing
audi created an autonomous off-roader
that uses flying drones to illuminate
the road instead of headlights show joe
the video
what it's ill as [ __ ] it's it's oh [ __ ]
oh my god they're ahead of the car the
[ __ ] headlights are ahead of the car
it's the illest [ __ ] i've ever seen
that's some star wars [ __ ]
right yeah precision drones if if you
have a key in your pocket they'll follow
you like
if you're walking in the woods it's
crazy
that thing looks wild it looks like some
[ __ ] jamie foxx drives already
he already has one of those yeah jimmy
fox probably already has this
he has one of those resvani's isn't that
what it's called it's like a resvani
tank
i ran into him at the gas station i was
like who the [ __ ] is driving that thing
jamie foxx what's up that thing looks
awesome though that audi that's a slick
looking car too that's crazy there's a
somewhere online there's a video
demonstration and it's probably going to
be electric
right yeah yeah yeah is it yeah
everything's electric now
look at this look at this [ __ ] it's
there
now look at this look at this look at
this watch when it's driving
oh [ __ ] that's the headlights yes the
headlights are ahead
making the road bright yo that's some
gangster [ __ ] right there son they're
flying like little ufos that's
nuts could you imagine if you saw that
drive by you somewhere yeah you'd be
like oh my god i think i saw an alien
that's crazy that's going to be the
future look at that [ __ ]
they fly ahead of you and illuminate the
road
that's bananas and you just have to
trust them with your little bitch-ass
lights
you got some sort of jeans fog lights
you have to trust the daddies that are
flying around that's how the
government's going to control you
they don't want to keep you keep you
going on their road no no you don't want
to look at that road that way it's dark
the drones only go on this road come on
son where can i get pizza
probably a pizza place fine again joe
come on man
you started like this man why are you
doing this to me we'll find a pizza
place for you
what do you what kind of pizza you want
thin crust i could get a pizza pizza
a pizza pizza a piece of pizza
a piece of pizza yeah pizza pizza
i gotta get some more gauze too man
let's take it let's take a flight we're
gonna get some meat
yeah yeah we can just we can just end
this it's already 4 35.
we've been doing this forever oh he and
i have been doing this for four and a
half hours
i know man he'd been disrespecting my
gunshot wound i didn't i told
jaime i didn't right never
it's not true none of this is true
teamwork is dream work um thanks dave
that was fun
oh my god next time we'll do it for real
for like really yeah for sure 100
percent i would love it thank you
that was fun thank you thanks for the
candle thanks for the cream thanks for
everything
thanks for everything uh donna what
about the show rfk
stadium rfk stadium uh dc improv the
traditional thanksgiving show
and the date is november 28th
and pixar's uh soul comes on christmas
day
on disney places keep people focused on
the show what
i'm saying the 28th joe you keep
disrespecting me man
i want people to come and see you the
way you say it trying to find out where
the tickets are there it is all right
there it is so the driving comedy at rfk
no i'm trying to promote your show sorry
parkupdc.com so go to parkupdc.com it's
the 28th
your traditional yes that's it thank you
sir
thank you enjoyed it oh i love you too i
love your dog
she's awesome all right bye everybody
you